[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
everyone um
just
we got sandra somewhere or is she
right
well we're on the clock so
uh so many apologies
uh obviously uh council stewart for
lateness
uh conflicts of interest to be recorded
speed launch stuff lost in there thank
you
thank you
okay so
a few acknowledgements firstly
excuse me um
we've got um three year victories of
former
community board
and board members who've passed away
between our last meeting and um
over the christmas period so firstly uh
warwick reston who was a former member
of the ringura
advisory board um
2004-2010
ian reed a former member of the ashley
air advisory group and hust water
advisory group
and giles beaglehole who's a former
member of a number of
local ranger groups including the ranger
advisory group
2004 to 2007
chair of the northbrook a wetland
advisory group and rengar a museum
committee and the keep render a
beautiful group
so those three members have made a
significant contribution to our
community over the years
it would be appropriate for us to stand
and observe a moment of silence out of
respect
thank you
struggling with my glasses that are
fogging and then i can't see when i take
them off so
um
just just under acknowledgements we also
had a young lad from
who walked the length of the country
um i just wouldn't mind the council if
they don't mind acknowledging
their achievement
from the bottom of the south to the top
of the north it's a very um very
suitable thank you
i'm sorry i
had a name on the tip of my tongue but
it's just disappeared i'm sure um if you
remember
um also
under 3.2 new year's honor peter simpson
who's
a resident of wood end was awarded the
new zealand order of merit for services
uh the education some of you may
remember peter was long-term
uh principal of belfast school he was on
the foundation board and chair for
tomato ulu and
has actually given extensively to
education
over the years for a number of programs
so
we were approached and wrote letter of
support
for his honour and it was great to see
that he was acknowledged as wife adrian
as the principal of um bullying school
so
it was nice to acknowledge that
also like to acknowledge at the weekend
blackpool's department's still finally
able to celebrate their 150th
anniversary
they had been trying for a number of um
okay i think andrew mench and three
occasions
excuse me
but there were
a number of councillors that were
presenting the chair of the community
board
just said that um you know overnight at
sutton tools unfortunately hit the
devastating fire so i just wanted to
mention
our thoughts to the employees and
obviously the business owners down there
for
that devastating loss and hopefully
get back on their feet and not too
distant future um i'd like to also just
acknowledge i went on
a thursday to the museum's um
uh
fur fangs and something opening that
they had in there well this is a book
that was written by james ryan who's
aged you may have seen it in the paper
he's age 12 from
sefton school it's an absolutely
outstanding
piece of work he spoke
at the opening and it was really
fantastic he's gone in there and done a
lot of research
but to
publish a book at the age of 12 is
something quite amazing and he's from a
district they were going to try and do a
launch here at the library but
it's not working out as easily so i
thought i'd mention him today
i'd have a signed copy which was
fantastic so i'll hand that round to you
all but
a very
bright and enthusiastic young
student at age 12. so i'll pass that
around and you may wish to look at that
at some particular point
i think the name
um for what never mentioned before is uh
emma tim's i think with a great name
all right so they are the
acknowledgements and this is anything
anyone else wants to acknowledge
we come to the confirmation of minutes
which page is 1750
uh in the agenda
some are prepared to move there's a true
correct record that's count strategies
that's seconded by
councillor becky
i'll put those all those who have a pci
entry
declare those carried
we also have minutes of the
extraordinary meeting of the council on
the 10th of december pages 51-53 moved
by
council milling seconded by councillor
edmund i'll put that all those in paper
please say i
contrary to clear that carried
is there any matters rising from those
nights
and we'll deal with item 4.3 when we're
in our public excluded
we've now got
kind of deputations and presentations
and firstly
uh we've got five point one which is
carlos and lauren cozzini
east excuse me for the pronunciation
um
carlos you're most welcome to come
forward to our table now um and you're
going to present your views on ski
bridge
row speed limit so
welcome to our table up 10 minutes uh
and within that time there may be a
couple of questions from colleagues so
thank you for your time and um
you've worked out the speaker system and
pressing the button so that's really
great thank you
oh thank you councillors for your time
uh
it's been in consideration of this
request i know you're very busy and
with things like this big fire down in
kaiapoin weekend you've got lots on your
hands so thank you very much for taking
the
thoughts and considerations of residents
on sku bridge and flatston road into
consideration at this time
my wife and i uh resident at 150
skewbridge road we've been living there
since
2011.
the section of road that
i'm talking about
is from the rangiora uh
side of the sku bridge where the speed
limit changes from 80 to 100 kilometres
uh the long straight uh
that
is in the direction of euro there are
two large bins um
and then there's a long straight that
heads along flaxton road the road
changes name without any
uh uh you're not on a different road on
the same stretch of road to the 80
kilometer zone that is
on flaxton road
just north of camel park so
in recent years
all of the compound improvements
have been fantastic
in our district
the commuter from europa can make it to
the corner of innis road and
cranford street
without
a single traffic light
however the the consequences of all this
is that scubage and flaxton rose
are being treated as a motorway
which
they're not and i sincerely appeal to
you all to do uh the sensible thing
and to reduce the speed um
along that road an interest of safety
for the residents and the road users
the timeline of uh why i'm here um
my wife and i uh moved to and family
moved to the north island for a couple
of years
for work um we arrived back at the
beginning of last year
and like people do when they've been
away for a long time or even on a long
holiday
you look at the uh gate that once
mending and think oh what
haven't i done that and uh
um and you go and fix it but um we
looked at we sensed this increase in
traffic and we thought uh um you know
was it like this before we left surely
uh maybe we got used to it um
at any rate uh not long after we got
back uh some friends from christchurch
are unfamiliar with the area
were nearly rear-ended
attempting to
come onto our property
and we started asking a few questions
and we noticed how the road around the
silver stream uh subdivision had been
improved in our absence
and um
at any rate we we considered some of the
places that we'd seen in the north
island are not dissimilar to rangara in
particular cambridge and the waikato
which is toe graphically similar they're
completely reliant on the
ditches for the drainage of the
primeval swamps to make land inhabitable
and the roads system that they've got
there which is a legacy uh probably
similar age to skewbridge and flaxton
roads that are bound by ditches
and land posts and what have you and
they're not they're not motorways and
and
lots of crosses on the road similar to
the skewered road flax and road bin
and and lots of double yellow lines and
80k zones and sort of you know maybe
maybe we should sort of think about um
doing something so we wrote an email to
mr gordon on the 23rd of march
and uh had a phone call with councillor
blackie the representative of our ward
um
in this email we went to explain who we
were how long we'd live there
that when when um
really happy to see the positive changes
in north canterbury since we've been
away there's positive changes of
population growth and
uh and
increasing industry and so forth and
we're not lightweights we're not
anti-progress we're um
but uh um you know that we sort of don't
feel that comfortable pulling out of our
driveway and
going onto the road in case there's a
some person overtaking
someone else
along this long stretch
as you come off these improved
motorways that the
district benefits from um on
south side of the waimakariri bridge and
people driving home and
thought you know we're only talking
about 3k of road
of which about
600 meters of it is a series of bins
that you can't really speed around
anyway
if you do you'll end up as graeme
stevenson as reported to the council on
multiple occasions of your car in the
ditch or
or upside down or through one of his
fences there and um so really you know
three kilometers minus about 600 meters
is you know 2 400 meters
and a quick mass and if you reduce the
speed limit from 80 to 100 and
from 100 to 80 sorry and followed the
rules
you know there would mean
20 seconds extra one way
to trip and you know i don't
rethink that
seconds
per commuter voyage is going to
make this living among euro west um less
appealing
or
be a
an impairment to growth
or
the general enjoyment of living out here
um
yeah so
at any rate um mia gordon um through his
staff arranged to come visit our
property
on the 22nd of april um and with uh
other
council stuff i unfortunately wasn't
present um i just started a new position
i had to go away for work but my wife
was there and
this occurred at 5 30 in the evening
thursday evening i believe it was
so busy time and there was about 35
residents of skubridge
and flaston roads including people from
camel park and from mulcox road
representing about 20 households and
they all explained
what their
experiences were and answered some
questions and very
cordial uh meeting bill accounts um
i spoke then in 17th of may to the
kaiapoi tahiri board and
explained the same thing of the
observations
and then after the lockdown i
participated in the video and interview
for the let's talk
public consultation
in the past two months i believe graeme
stevenson is notified
staff member
kathy graham
of one car on this roof and two cars
through um
his fence that might not have been
notified to the police
and therefore
evidence that could be used for a
statistical or
expert analysis of
safety or
unsafety or stretchy road
at any rate
it's also due to population increase a
lot more people are using the road
taking debris and rush to the south
transfer station
and on the periodic clean outs of the
ditch we find
lots of wood and tyres and things like
this and they just the the compounding
progress is such a good thing for the
district but
for those
roads that made them
not as uh
safe i believe
and then as do the other residents that
attended on the 22nd of april when the
mayor come to visit um
so um to the extent that you know my
son's interested in getting a driver's
license that's his prerogative and i
don't think that's um
a major one but there's a young fellow
that the rest of his friends are getting
their license but he doesn't want to
pull out onto that road so
um that's really it in a nutshell um i
thank you for your time
thank you carlos um there may be some
questions so
any questions councilor edmund
thank you for coming along carlos um
two things firstly
do you reverse out of your driveway or
are you able to turn
on sight and drive out
your driving we
drive the car out um with the
engine or bonnet
ahead of us so here we drive our um
don't reverse that we
drive out
would you say that speed or the volume
of traffic which would be your main
concern
combination of both especially the
overtaking of
vehicles that are already doing at or
near speed limit as is the major one
the ancient dc limit was a hundred k's
um
you'd be aware that that's a limited
speed zone
from the bridge towards rangero
i believe that from
and it's got the circular sign with the
black yes
so that's a 100 kilometer yeah
yeah
right thank you
councilbar
thank you for your really clear
submission it's very good to hear um in
your experience of the cars that have
ended up having crashes were they doing
the speed limit or were they doing more
than the speed limit
oh i wouldn't know
we hear the things we've heard
motorbikes vehicles high revving
um
you know
so there's this driver
yeah i mean it's it's driver behavior um
but
it's um
i'm not a transport engineer but i think
a common sense point of view is uh
with the increased
number of commuters especially
that
it's just it look it looks like and it's
treated like a motorway but that it's
not a right motorway and when vehicles
do come off that generally
um you know high
consequence
graphic incidences rather than whoops
yeah
and you mentioned the issue with um
turning into your property would
improving the road's shoulders alleviate
that factor
well i mean um no doubt yes
but uh we we indicate plenty in advance
and
you know we get people giving us the
fingers and
and you know like we've we've caused
them a considerable displeasure but um
you know the the
there's we as residents
we drive as safely as we can and that
means you know we will at our property
we maintain a pull-off areas on both
sides
of the road with gravel so that you're
not pulling onto grass and and all of
this and we never pull any of this uh
just stopping on a boat on the road and
then indicating to go and never we
always get off on but
compared to
2011 or 12 when that road went all
through the by the koi poi cemetery
and and and predated uh west rung aura
completely whether it was fields open
fields
um that road you know uh i think it was
sealed in the 60s
early 60s it hasn't changed it was
designed for a population that is
you know
in a yearbook somewhere not not this
population
thank you
thank you carlos um
would you feel safer if
we reduced the speed down that road to
80 kilometer kilometers an hour
yes
yes i would
um
i
i don't want to get hit by someone doing
80 preferred not to get by someone at
all but but
but just a layman's you know
whatever the
you know
you know impact forces velocity times
mass or whatever i don't know but i
think from layman's point of view so i'd
far rather get hit by a car doing 80
and i think that if there are a car
cars overtaking
doing someone doing 80 they will be
doing 100 they won't be doing
120 or
or whatever it is we never see speed
cameras down there either i'm sure
they'll be a good place to
probably put some but that's not there
well um there's not going to be any
further questions carlos can i say thank
you on behalf of the council for taking
the time to present to us today also
writing and both counselor williams and
myself both attended that meeting
with other residents and it was
insightful and helpful to us as there's
been your presentation today
we've got uh next um mr chief i know i
just was gonna let you know we've got
jim jerry who's next
but you're welcome to stay and listen to
jim's presentation
i'm going to take the agenda items
around speed um next after mr jarrod
so you'd be most welcome to say and
listen to that if you wished if you
choose not to is recorded audio live
streams you can watch that from the
comfort of your home they share a few
jews but um
i just wanted to let you know what
options you have if you want to stay in
this into the conversations i greatly
appreciate your hosting
being here today thank you for your time
uh now i'd like to welcome mr jim jerry
the chair of the ringer hd community
board thank you for uh coming along
today jim thank you mr mayor i'm here
just to talk very briefly
about the board's decision on the speeds
in these areas
i'm not here to debate the issues with
you
i'll leave that to to your to your
wisdom but
from a board perspective uh
we were pleased with the thoroughness of
the consultation the public consultation
we thought the staff reports were
excellent covered the issues and so did
their answers to questions
the board were supportive of the
recommendation that came
to you with three exceptions
uh
cousins barnett and williams voted
against it and so did board member
wells who interestingly neither spoke
nor asked a question so i couldn't
tell you why he was opposed but
really the main opposition was about the
speed on the
flexton road the fernside road and the
mount thomas road well i won't elaborate
too much on the flagship road you've
heard plenty from
carlos except to observe
the changes to that road in the last 12
months
it has now become a major exit from
rangiora to christchurch i use it all
the time because of the blockage at line
side going through southbrook at big
hours it's just bedlam through there and
it's a much quicker way
so more and more people are using
that on on town in fernside flex and and
i agree with carlos if you only need to
speak and he mentioned
graeme stevenson you only need to talk
to him to really know the chaos
that's happening on that road there are
so many
close goes and it's all about speed in
my view
the other opposition of course was to
fernside and
in particular our fernside staff told us
that
it's a regular hot spot now for
accidents
uh you'll be aware of the major
crossings lanes road and plascus while
they've been dealt with that doesn't
stop the traffic still screaming up and
stopping
at the last moment in fact i understand
from what staff said that
in sections and rural areas in the
review
being reviewed contributed to
15 serious and fatal accidents in the
last 10 years that's that's very very
high
the mount thomas road well
i i really discount that because the
mean speed on that road is 70 to 74 on
the staff report
and it's been recommended for 80 so
that's well below that at any rate so it
shouldn't
be
be an issue
look i think the best way to sum it up
and i would be i will be very
disappointed if council stays where it
is and doesn't support
the board's view
because it's all about road safety none
of us like speed restrictions i don't i
used to be quite a mad driver i probably
stand
but the fact of the matter is
speed kills
and
it's worth noting that the speed
restrictions are becoming the norm
wherever you wherever you go i've just
been around
northern southland and central when the
many of the roads now are atks where
there is erroneous
or not wide straight roads
um
so speed restrictions are the norm
due to high death rates on the road it's
the only way to protect other road users
maurice harris who is a farmer i noted
with some amusement reading your minutes
that kirsten said she was now sorry
councillor bennett
now a
rural councillor well i don't see what
that has to do with it
interestingly you might
you might recognize that two of our
board members are existing farmers
they've both supported the change
the chair farm for 40 years he's
supported the change i think the best
way to sum it up is that
is
the question morris harris an empty
sensible farmer on the main road to
oxford from angora
he said he reluctantly supported the
motion
he noted that accidents were generally
caused by driver error and not often had
a lot to do with roads
however speed reductions was the only
way to reduce the damage during an
accident
he commented it was the way forward i'll
leave it at that
other than to say
i've been i am disappointed
as a community board chair that the
council
have chosen to ignore a board
recommendation makes you wonder
quite honestly what the point of having
community boards is if they don't get
their recommendations listened to
particularly when it involves the safety
of others thank you mr chair
yeah thanks thanks mr jurid we
appreciate um your um presentation is
there any questions
councilman
thank you very much mr jared that's very
very succinct and um interesting
feedback from the board um what i'd like
to ask you is changing the speed limit
without enforcement do you believe that
will change the driver behaviour on this
road i think it'll help i mean
enforcement's not a matter for the
councils that's a matter for them for
the ministry and it's an impossible job
for them you'd be better to talk to one
of your colleagues who's an expert in
that
in in that field just because you have
more traffic officers on the road it
doesn't mean traffic necessarily slows
it does slow when someone blinks the
light set you till there's a cop sitting
down the road
but no
i
people speed because
the road is
seems okay to them they don't understand
that
a tractor can come out a gateway a kid
coming on a rural road can come out on a
horse or a pony and actions happen
you've had examples of that twin side
quite recently
thanks jim uh any further questions
thank you
sorry i didn't see your hand sorry yeah
yep
just
interested in your comment about voting
against community board
um
this council assumed that it should
rubber stamp everything the community
board puts across its table
no i
i i think that that's an interesting
question and this is not the first time
that
i've experienced the council
not agreeing with the community board
but the fact of the matter is
if you've got community boards that are
liaison between the community and the
council they are close to their
communities they live in the area they
know what is happening they know about
the hoons on this road or the hoons on
that road and council in this wisdom has
given them responsibility and put them
in place so if you're going to have
elected bodies you need to take notice
notes of them
and
and in fact i believe they should have
more delegations but that's another
issue so he's suggesting this council
isn't taking on us
i don't know i'll find out i don't think
we're late
i don't think we should get into that
debate um it's a point that has raised
interpretation you may wish to pick it
up and debate yourself council atkinson
um can i
is there any other questions uh council
ward yes a question my question would be
would it be possible for you to please
to acknowledge that as a ranger ashley
committee board and counsellor i
all have always approved of oh yeah
thank you again a debating point that
you can
pick up and debate yourself council
award thank you i don't think there's
any further questions uh sorry council
redmond
uh thank you mr gerard for coming along
and giving us your thoughts um would you
support proposal to upgrade flaxton
flexton hubridge road
to reflect its new role as a major
arterial given the increased volume of
traffic well
i support any upgrading of road that
brings greater safety for the motorists
on them
bridge and skewbridge area of course i'd
support an upgrade there i can't believe
anyone wouldn't
okay
thank you you indicating a question
there comes the brian
oh well i cleared a conflict but it's
it's
mr gerard you i've served for a long
time
you as mayor and his councillor
i've been here 21 years you've been out
here nearly as long and various
with regard to community boards would
you be surprised to know that in that
period there have been five occasions
where i've voted against the community
the numerous hundreds of recommendations
for advice
that there have been five occasions i
think i think you've made your point
counselor brian thank you it's a
debating point and then the event you
don't need to respond to that mr jared
no thank you look jim so can we say
thank you for um presenting the boards
of you here today and the points you've
made you're welcome to remain for other
debate if you wish um
and we're going to go into that shortly
so thank you thank you mr jared
all right so uh we're now going to come
to um adjourn to business um 6.1 which
is um pi point to here we board our wall
area um speed limits now
um following
our workshop this morning
we have uh rearranged the agenda
slightly to
when i say rearrange realign the agenda
in line with some of the questions that
members had and preferences around how
we deal with
the speed limit so we'll just take a
minute for you to get those
thanks kelly
i have to remind myself what we have
actually um done heads for a second
[Applause]
okay so you'll have the items in front
of you and so
perhaps i just described how we're going
to go through those so firstly
we're going to deal with uh 6.1 first
and so
table 1
table 2
so a and b table 1 table 2
table 3
and then
d
we will deal with this one
table c a table 4 will be taken
separately as per conversation this
morning around those particular measures
uh table
eight uh sorry 8.1 we'll go through
those when we come to that but
you'll note that skewbridge
area will be treated separately as well
as table seven and then table six
we'll take those items
those roads separately as indicated this
morning but we'll take to decide better
to put blackstone skewbridge in one
table
rather than because it does cover
partially two ward areas but actually
it's better to deal with there's one as
opposed to multiple agendas because it
just gets confusing not only for me but
um
i'm sure it is for you so that
broadly makes sense to you all
we've had good conversation on this
topic um
and we've heard the adaptations that
have been in presentations before us so
before we come to the item just like to
see if joanne
or ellie um we can acknowledge uh all
your work ali um which has been
extraordinary so thank you and thank you
for picking this up with our staff after
our briefing this morning so quickly
this and by the way there's maps here as
well team uh
that were asked for so
um
hopefully that gives a bit more clarity
uh about how that looks they were in our
agendas but i i appreciate it's much
easier to see one in front of you than
one on the screen
i i'm sitting that category myself so
joe in there early if there's anything
you would like to add
um yeah i was just gonna say look we
have worked through this um issue of
speed limits on a number of occasions
and also at the briefing this morning
and these recommendations are in line
with some hopefully further information
to help the decision-making process so
nothing else from me
is there any questions of staff
okay well i'm
i'm going to test the machine with the
recommendation 6.1
so a b table 1 table 2 table 3
and uh d e and f do i have a second f
for that and we'll deal with uh as i say
c
with table four separately so you just
wonder whether we can
move a separately
uh i'm here to take this
oh
okay all right um
uh do you want me to take uh a bit now
well firstly let's do let's do a so
uh moving uh
put taking a so that's moved and
seconded uh by myself and counselor ward
um do you wish i was gonna hold my
discussion to the wrist any point so i
had any further speakers to point a so
i've got the recommendation all those
favor please say aye
contract
to clear that carried
then we'll take uh item b that says
table 1 2
3. and in d e and f
uh
moving that do you wish to second that
council award yes okay or it doesn't
matter who that does accounts award
so justin speaking to this briefly i
think we've extensively looked at the
topic of speed limits
um it's been through an extensive
process that
has already been outlined there was a
briefing to portfolio holders council
briefings community board briefings and
decisions council decision to consult
community consultation then back to
boards then to council
before christmas and now
the message hasn't changed
through that time
that's from what it is around road
safety there were a number of proposals
that were put up first
that you know through testing that with
elected members they were reduced
significantly about where some of those
changes were originally proposed
uh
i'm not all i'll be honest not all i
feel totally comfortable myself but the
reality is is that when
you look at
the advice we get from our staff the
feedback we've had from our community i
went to the meeting that carlos
mentioned earlier
there were some pretty impatient uh
people very concerned about their safety
graeme
and his wife ali that were there were
virtually in tears with what they have
seen on their particular property and
who they've helped
out of ditches and other things and it
was quite
a compelling when you listen to that
i share the regional red safety
committee i know the message that goes
regionally and
the the the number of uh incidences that
are occurring and there is look to we're
trying to get alignment of messaging
right throughout canterbury right
throughout new zealand
about road safety the current message
for government is right to zero and it's
the one
uh we are working to
if we can make these changes and it
saves a life then that to me is worth my
vote um here today i heard jared and how
he lives
died since he's been in the role and i
found that quite a compelling case
actually i hadn't reflected
exactly that statistic here in our
district
as well as the information our chief
executive shared with us with his
experience previously with
being
with nzta
just picking up a point of question that
i think came from councillor redmond
around the flaxton skew bridge and road
safety that area is a priority for us we
are arguing with not arguing
putting forward strongly the case for
their investment on the skew bridge
because it desperately does need to
happen unfortunately it's not sitting in
their priority
but it doesn't mean that we give up on
the argument and keeping putting that
forward um because you do take your life
in your hands sometimes when you go
across there with large vehicles so
speed reduction through that net through
that area is just
i've been in those properties and i
certainly understand but the other
points we've made them well on these
points so the other just the comments i
wanted to make is there any further
speakers do you wish to speak counsel
yes i think it's really important that
as we grow we have more traffic on the
road um and there's more people coming
and going um we have to um regulate and
and assist with those people that are
living in the area so that they can exit
and get home safely and also i will also
say the layman's road the vaccine road
has really increased um since the
congestion on south brook road as soon
as possible because that will also take
a lot of the traffic on the eastern side
wrangler which is currently using
lehman's road lexson road instead of
south fork blindside road will take them
directly on the eastern side
to hindsight road and will save a lot of
congestion and a lot of traffic on
flagstone road so i will be advocating
to be to be bringing that forward
um as soon as possible because i think
that's really urgent as well as the
screw bridge
thank you any further speakers council
barnum
yes i am supporting um these three
tables on the agenda i do have some
concerns about flax syndrome going down
to 60 as a major arterial heading to the
rural areas
however it's a short space of time short
place of road so i guess that can be
managed however i refer you all to the
feedback from the community on page 161
of today's agenda
we have over 50 of our community on many
of these roads actually against the
speed limits that we are proposing today
that was reflected in the big debate at
the ranger ashley community board the
members were really divided over what
way to go on certain roads
overall many of these roads do need a
reduction at particularly unsealed roads
i actually support the reduction to 60k
on all the unsealed roads
however some of these roads that have
been designated in the council planning
documents as major arterial routes to
move residents from a to b
and are zoned rural or industrial do not
seem to justify dropping to lower speed
limits
and the rangara ashley community board
were concerned that if we drop speed
limits down to lower in certain areas it
will push traffic back onto the 100
kilometer road line side road and lead
to extra condition in the south brook
area which we have been trying to avoid
many members were not quite sure how to
express this in the debate and spoke to
me after the meeting unfortunately since
the resolution got was passed so the the
feedback from our community has been
divided on this um on on the kaiba one
i'm willing to
willing to support all unsealed roads
absolutely because i can see
um danger travelling over 60 and some of
those gravel roads that we are unable to
maintain with standard that would allow
you to do 80 kilometers now because we
do not have enough funding to do so
however i am still very uncomfortable
with supporting the fernside flagstone
area as these are major material roads
that are essential for our community to
get both um freight
people commuting traffic to actually
increase the economy of our district
thank you any further speakers custer
atkinson bothered by council love
williams well i wasn't going to speak
but um
i've taken into consideration what all
community boards have said about all of
our roads all the way through
and individual members and people that i
talk to in the community
and it is fair to say
that our consultation reflects what
people are telling me
i will be voting against all of these
because i think there are much better
mitigations we talked about time
and how
retraining drives all of those types of
things would take time
to come through well let me assure you
that uh outside my place has been 50k
50k
for the last 38 years
and i can also as well you since there's
a roundabout in there a safety measure
that the noise and speed from there
is hopeless
it's worse than ever was because there's
no enforcement i'd love to see the rural
roads and the in our police and using
their resources to sit in the back
of mount thomas road they're on a single
road waiting for the farmer to come down
this tractor exceeding 60 days
i mean it's just not going to happen the
realities are that the that driver and
attention
drivers failings
yes speed will contribute to what
happens in the crash
but
what i tried to allude to before is the
amount
of accidents that happen in our country
not in our district in our country
that are where people break the rules
they are not due to getting halfway on
the road with an 80 kilometer sign or 60
kilometer sign they are due to the
people breaking the rules that will not
change the red and white sign with a
black number in the middle of it i tend
to vote against the whole whole thing
thank you for the speakers
sorry council williams yes
yes while i support most of these
some of these i don't
but
i like um
opinion on
you've got flexed and wrote
are you speaking are you asking a
question oh it's actually going to
hopefully the staff might be asking okay
so you would like to ask a question yes
okay so
please ask your question yeah um
you've got um adks up to camel drive
would that be nothing more sensible and
you want a camel drive to be 60
kilometers all the way through there
bring the 60 kilometers from the
roundabout
just so that we're not uh dealing with
camel park here are you is that correct
camera park yeah yes you've got a wii
section here or 80 k's
and to me it would make more sense if
you want to
camel drive to go into um camel park
you'd say
and the 60 case you should bring that
60k area
all the way from southwark to kingwool
park
it would save a lot of money on signs
for example
because as soon as you go past campbell
park
it'll be automatically
but i'm happy for the question to be
answered for you now but just to let you
know it's not being dealt with in this
suite of recommendations it's going to
be dealt with within the next one
so just to answer that that would mean
that 60 kilometer in our area that was
proposed would need to be extended
further into the rural area on
uh flexton road and i actually don't
think there's an advantage in doing that
um
my personal opinion is you'd be to leave
it within 80 kilometer an hour area and
once you leave a roundabout and start
heading down flexton road
you wouldn't get combined with the 60
deer
okay further questions
or speakers
you watched
counsellors could you to your microphone
off
paul
did you wish to speak council meetings
yep
so
we've got some contentious issues here
and a lot of good questions being asked
but i look at the table on page 58 and
diligent
and it points
to a slightly different outlook and
obviously a little bit of confusion i
think in the public that has answered
these questions
where they were asked if skewbridge road
to flaxton road to the adk sign
should be changed down to 80. 63.2
percent of people said yes
that's a reasonable majority
now if you go up to the top of the table
and you see where they are talking about
flaxton road
only 33.7
and 45.6 respectively talking about the
urban side that goes through the
roundabout
and the
in the south of fernside through the
skewbridge
so
what i gather from that is that people
don't actually
didn't understand that
the the drop to 60 was actually being
proposed through that roundabout you
cannot drive adk through roundabout
it must be dropped it's it's not
possible to do that whether you like it
or not so i don't think people actually
understood
what was being proposed and why there
and i can understand that that stretch
of flaxton road where people aren't keen
because it is a nice wide open road in a
rural area
and a lot of drivers and things coming
off of it
but
with the parameters we have to work in
that being that we must have two
kilometers to have 100k limit
um that that
shrinks that down a little bit that
basically makes it so that we can't
have
the lower limits on either side
to keep that one small stretch at 100k
now as harlow's very rightly pointed out
it's going to put 20 seconds
on your
on your journey
now i personally like to drive up to the
speed light as quickly as possible and
drive at the speed limit
um
you know i like the rural roads that
they're um
the ease and quickness that one can
travel but
also
we all know faster the road bigger the
mess as has been pointed out
one would like would rather if you're
going to get hit by someone you'd rather
be hit by someone doing 80 than 100
and even though we have people who break
the rules people who speed and whatever
if you like why when you go to a
uh
dubious intersection why do you
instinctively slow down
when you're not sure about what other
people might do
because instinctively we know that if we
reduce our speed we reduce our chance of
harm
and if a road is at 80 kilometers an
hour
and
someone wants to overtake if they want
to do you know 100 or whatever even if
they're speeding they still don't have
to speed
as
much
to overtake that person so again the
seeds are still overall lower and also
reduces the amount of kinetic energy
going into that crash should there be
one
as much as i like to put my foot down
and go i don't see any reason why we
should not listen to our community here
and
the
information that had been given us to us
by staff and in zta
and
put these
limits through as proposed so i'm in
support of this and i hope that you will
all think about it
thank you
thanks council meetings any faith
speakers
i'm not going to exercise the right
reply because it's all been well said
regardless of what side you sit on
there's it's a fair debate so
i'll put the recommendation
um just being clear that we all
understand that we're going to come back
to
item c
i'll put that all those in favor please
say aye
country
i declare that carried and would you
like your late record that's rickinson
thank you
so now we're going to come to item c
which is table four
so um and we're just going to take this
table separately i wasn't advised that
members wanted to take individual
streets separately so
some are prepared to to move count
simply oh no sorry um
where did you sit on that one
[Music]
move as it is
table see
table c so um moved by council back he's
seconded by
off second dutch
is there any discussion
thank you mr mayor um
earlier this morning i i said i i stated
my opinion that i thought it was
unenforceable and i'm sticking to that
but in the debate we've had in the last
few hours it's become apparent that a
lot of the decisions we're making here
uh uh almost irrespective of the fact
whether they're enforceable or not
the the other point which i think anser
has made uh
recently or this morning is that um the
people who are going to break this 30 30
proposed limit
are our hoons um
it's a bit of a racer track down there
they're not going to take any notice of
the 30 just as they don't take any
notice of the 50 anyway it's not a big
deal one way or the other there are some
some traffic calming meters in there so
i've changed my mind since this morning
and i'm prepared to
not die in a ditch over it and let it go
at 30.
okay um i'm not going to exercise uh
seeking the council reckons and well
just for clarity i'm not suggesting
homes i'm talking about people who who
speed or break the law that's what i'm
talking about because
i've seen people who don't whom do
exactly that
um any further speakers oh sorry council
bars i just would like members to note
that we have no other 30 kilometre an
hour speed limit within the kaiapoi area
or in the ranger town centre the only
place that we have 30 kilometer in our
limits
are actually in the beach communities
and that's actually caused some problems
for people because it's kind of
inconsistent with the environment
and once you drop a speed limit to 30
it's really really impossible to bring
it back up there's also been a lot of
chaos in christchurch in the 30k zones
and that in a major city
the fact that these areas here are
um slower driving areas because the road
condition is not better actually makes
you drive to the conditions but 50 is
still a perfectly acceptable speed limit
in other areas so i really would caution
members this will set a precedent today
we drop this down to 30 we will get huge
calls from the community to make high
street 30 to make williams street 30 and
other areas in our community
okay further speakers council redmond
followed by council award
thank you mr mayor um i won't be
supporting this motion
i'm unconvinced that there is reason or
need
to reduce the speed limit from 50ks to
30 hayes
um these areas are largely open
and essentially no residential
properties in them
i suspect that in actual reality very
few drivers will be exceeding 50
especially if you're going to a boat
ramp with the boat um i suspect mean
speed is going to be somewhere between
30 and 40
kilometers per hour but um i think it's
the need of the weed and i can't really
see any justification for reducing it
because the wood
um once again i think that um it's sort
of a safety a safety issue so that's how
i feel about it
further speakers counts the meetings
the condition of the roads in the area
like 30 seems an awfully slow speed the
condition of the roads in that area are
pulling um i i challenge you to try to
do 50ks on that road without needing to
see your chiropractor straight after and
i don't know if our intention is to
leave that road that way
but
um i do know again looking at those that
were surveyed that raven key 62.3
percent supported charles street 57.5
percent supported jolly street s keaton
drive 57.1 percent of people surveyed
supported therefore all support the
recommendations thank you just just
excuse me just for a moment i think uh
we don't have any members of public
health because council directs part of
our bubbles so if you wish to you can
remove the masks
if you want to breathe aside
sorry that may change the status quo in
here right uh sorry question count
stricken you just um
probably to join it's my understanding
that um
raven key
uh
charles street um certainly north of
where we're talking uh sorry we swear i
missed
we were talking those roads that uh
council meetings was talking about are
actually brand new roads that have been
been done and
probably 70 to those roads no one
actually lived on
is that correct
so raven key the reason for the proposed
30 kilometer in our
area down through the air is due to the
cycle path connecting through there and
across to mexican bridge there's also a
school adjacent so again pedestrian
safety for kids going accessing and out
of the school
charles street jolly street and ash
keaton drive have all been upgraded and
there's been some relatively significant
traffic coming going there to try and
encourage
lower speeds we've obviously got
activities such as the dog park people
getting in and out of vehicles and
loading and loading dogs the sports
fields
so there's a lot of recreational use
down there and it's trying to support
that
recreational use in those two locations
by
having a
lower speed limit which reflects the
activity that's occurring in those areas
questions given it
what's trying to be portrayed there's
any parking in my understanding outside
the dog park which is off the road
um there are no houses down there which
you didn't ask my question on there is
no houses in that area that i'm aware of
um you know we're painting a picture
here that isn't quite true is that
correct
[Music]
sorry i'm not trying to paint a picture
that's not true we do have people
parking and loading and unloading new
pets down there there's no houses no
that's correct okay i think we'll move
forward thank you um so any further
speakers
councilman if you want to exercise right
apply i'm happy to let you do so
very frankly yeah um so joanne's covered
it quite well um raven key's got school
in the back issue um charles street has
got the dog park and the honda forest
and a lot of recreational walking and
and um all the road down to ashley a lot
of people are towing boats through there
so all in all from from the safety point
of view um
our support i support the mission um be
it as i said before that um good luck
with the enforcement of it
okay i'm going to put the recommendation
of
c in table four all this in favor please
ai
country
to clear that carried but i think we
might just get a division to be clear on
that
no
yes
it's it's carried thank you
all right so that deals with the kaiapoi
to e um
speed limits so now we come to
a regular
there any introductory remarks joanne or
ellie you'd like to make with respect to
these speed limits no nothing further
okay so um
i'm just um
what i'm going to propose to do as well
to see early do you want me to take the
receiver report first
yeah so
so i'm going to move uh that we received
the report let's say seconded by
councillor atkinson
um it's really nothing really to make at
that point so i'll put that all those in
favor please say aye
contrary declare that carrots in i'm
going to deal with b
table 1
c table 2
d table 3
e table four
if
table five
uh and then i through to in and i'm
gonna i'm happy to move that someone
prepares a second seconded by council
award
um i'm sorry yes so the only ones that
we're not taking uh
would use six and seven that's correct
it should take separately so is everyone
clear on that
what i said i said in the previous
debate which applies so i'm not going to
add anything further at this point do
you wish to speak against the world
okay any further speakers
i'll put sorry east council varnish
once again um i support 90 of what's on
here however i have grave reservations
about table d
um
oxford road is a a rural road and um
yes there are times when there's quite a
lot of traffic and the traffic drops to
80k naturally but
on general times there's actually no
reason why you couldn't 100 kilometers
on there and be completely safe
outside of the school hours
and outside of the commuting hours slow
down anyway there's a lot more traffic
going on that road so to me dropping
adks past
fernside school and that's rich of
completely rural looking roads with very
few entrances
is pushing the urban limits too far our
urban boundary
is layman's road
it's not burnside school
and at the moment what we're doing here
today by dropping into 80 that we're
pushing out into making a rural area
into an urban fringe which is
inconsistent with other areas in our
district
so for major arterial roads i still have
a great concern but i'm not going to
done a ditch over this one it's going
from 100 to 80. most of the time when
this commute is traffic there it is
dropping to 80 naturally
however there are going to be some very
unhappy people with over 50 of the
people surveyed not wanting this rural
area to drop to 80 kilometers period
for the speakers
um
you did do you wish to speak now you
didn't really reserve it but i'm happy
to allow it this once
i i would really like to say that that
it is important i'm up there pass a
fun side school in that school area
people
travel far too fast at 100k it's very
unsafe i would never bike up there and i
think that um there is a lot of traffic
but needs to progressively slow down
coming into the um
into angular
um
failing that road quite often um
i think adks uh i would really like to
see that happen because it's
i'm afraid i've seen too many nemesis
around that area and and people coming
out of those side roads without really
stopping and looking so i'm i would be
really much in favor of it at 2 80.
thank you for the speakers
i'll put the recommendation
all those in favor please say hi
contrary
declare that kerry would like your vote
recorded
so then um the next part is uh
table what's g table six now
um i think you want to
counsel about it are you happy we deal
with this as one table or do you want to
deal with the roads individually i have
to move
one table okay so
um
for i realize you have a um uh it's
maybe beside move fashion um
table six and i've taken the ca second
by council award
i don't wish to speak um as you really
wish to speak council award
okay fifth speakers
so you're moving that lehman stayed at
60 so you're just amending the others
okay do you have a is there a second for
that second account sir williams
mr speak yes i'm perfectly well aware
that i'm going to lose this vote but um
i i really have to talk about this as a
counselor who lives on 100 kilometer in
our hunt road
and has 19 entrances in our two
kilometers stretch of road
um while we are not as busy we're on a
hill and the people come roaring down
dave's road um and it is very difficult
for my daughter who's just got her
license to try and exit our driveway she
has to be extremely careful but drivers
do have to be extremely careful in 100k
rural rural areas and it comes back to
driver behaviour
this area
it does not
look residential it's lifestyle
and a lot of our lifestyle areas are 100
kilometers across our district
and i really do believe that we need to
keep consistency to
encourage people to actually travel at
the speed that the environment shows us
we had a 50-50 response from residents
the reason being they don't want to be
paying for tickets
if they enter an area that looks totally
like the 100k road they've just come
from they're going to continue doing
100k and a sign will make no difference
the only thing for studies have shown
the only thing that makes a real
difference to driver speed is a
enforcement that they'll get tickets or
b that they will actually um see a
change in the road environment like it
gets busier
in these side roads off oxford road
we're not going to see enforcement we're
not going to see police sitting on
todd's rotary often on flexton road on
this part very often we're not going to
see them
on those middle pieces
the the issue that we've got is
we're actually creating inconsistencies
in our district and we're discouraging
people from commuting in our district
into the town of rangiora
i am concerned that putting up a sign
should not be seen as the bill and endor
to actually change the driver behaviour
that we're seeing currently
what we need to work on is education we
need to work on proving our shoulders to
allow there to be room for people to
move if something happens or if they
encounter a rural vehicle on these roads
these roads do not look like 80
kilometers per hour and we will have
exactly the same problem we have on
river road when we drop the speed limit
to 50 kilometers an hour but we do not
see people traveling at 50 kilometers an
hour very often on that road because of
the fact that one side is completely
rural it doesn't make sense
i'm concerned that we are using speed
limits as a panacea to try and improve
road safety when we should be doing is
improving the condition of our roads
that have a lot of traffic on them now
increasing traffic is not a reason just
to drop the speed limit
i absolutely don't want to see accidents
and absolutely there wouldn't be a
single person here that would ever want
to see anybody
injured on these roads but changing from
100 to 80 in these roads is only going
to upset the rural community who have to
come in to work and play in rangyura and
we want to encourage them to come in
the people who bought on these roads
knew they were buying on a rural road as
they die
the people who live on these roads
should not get to dictate to the rest of
the community what the speed limit is
it should be an over the district
decision so in this portion of the road
i do not see these roads have urbanized
enough when they are in rural or
industrial areas to actually bring them
up to this sort of speed limit
so i encourage you to please
reconsider keeping it at 100k
until we can see some improvement in the
road condition that we have some funding
from wakakotahi to do so
that we can actually see
the value in making this extra cost to
our district by changing speed limits
constantly in rural areas that don't
justify it
am disappointed in this report
and i will say that now because i have
seen no accident statistics to back up
this data
i've seen no
evidence that there is increased
accident on these roads with the amount
of traffic the accidents we're seeing
fatals on
out in the rural areas like burnt hill
tram road
so i've seen some i've seen some injury
accidents they have been caused
predominantly by people ignoring road
signs
or ignoring actual areas that they
should be driving or traveling at a
speed that's far and excessive 100
kilometers per hour
so it comes back to drive it education
it comes back to improving road
condition
and otherwise a rural road in our
district
should be 100 kilometers per hour under
the current
national guidelines
thank you
account the whims of the amendment
do you wish to speak
you did
yeah would you like to speak to it
no no i said the secret council williams
yes i agree 100 yeah um i follow on from
[Music]
what um from the land safety um
committee there the automobile
association saying
and they're having a problem all over
the whole of new zealand at the moment
by dropping roads
from 100ks to 80s like 80 kilometers now
but the roads don't look like they're 80
kilometer zone roads
and
and
probably the biggest fault is wakataki
because
they aren't funding councils properly
to actually improve these roads so and
the shoulders and the roads and
widths of some of these roads and and
whatever you see it's that's a problem
so all we're doing is
trying to drop the speed of the roads to
get to the road to zero better but it's
not working even though it is getting
dropped because it's that condition of
the roads and um
most conditions so i can't support this
um and
there's also going to be a flow-on
effect because you slow up one area of
some of the roads it's going to make the
other roads more congested because all
of a sudden i believe there's going to
be a
slow group of traffic which are closer
together and it's going to um impound
the the whole
flow-on effect and some of this will
impact on our
very very busy south brook road as well
which is going to make separate road
worse and we've always got a major
problem there so
i just can't support this it's not
doesn't make
sense
uh castlewood
actually it does make sense in my view
because if you um start the 80ks where
we we started to come in to into an
urban area you need to start to slow
down but also
because we're going down flaxton road
and continuing on if you're doing 80ks
further back and on flow with 80ks you
consistently
have have a slowing down which is much
safer for tractors coming out with
children
and people accessing in their area to
schools there's a high road usage um
joining up to where these are and i
think that
it makes sense to bring everything down
to 80k um so that everyone's slowing
down so people exiting people is
terrified of exiting out of their
properties because people are going zoom
at 100ks or they're passing and
i think that um i'll be supporting this
lower speed limit i think it's a much
safer speed limited i think it's
consistent with what we're trying to
achieve around the perimeter of the
township until we can get
and alleviate some of the pressures on
the west side of this the town and get
the east side flowing better
we've got more traffic on road
we've got
all the time and i think that um
it's proven that if the speed limits are
reduced a little bit 80 80 you've
traveled at 80 down the main from picked
into christchurch you know it's so much
safer
and um i think that
i'll be supporting this reduction i
think that um
it will be more consistent to what we're
trying to achieve around the perimeter
of the town
you i'm going to vote against the
amendment i don't disagree with
councillor barnett on the question of
education
shoulder work enforcement i feel logical
things but i actually and
i think ellie and the team have done an
absolutely superb job
with work that she's put into the
reporting
running the process it's been extensive
consultation and i really do genuinely
believe in the integrity of that process
i don't want to piece me without going
through these now and changing these
while they've been out i i appreciate
what council barnett's uh talking about
i've lived in rural community most of my
life up for last but for the last two
years when i moved into india so i
certainly understand what it's like to
live in the rural community and also to
commute we've got growth
all those other things that are there
slowing these down to these levels i
think makes sense having used these
rates myself i understand it appreciate
these two schools taught with it um so
i'll be voting against the amendment
any fifth speakers i'm prepared to let
you have a rather reply if you'd like to
counsel about
would you like to
do you want to do a right reply you can
if you want you don't have to okay
i'll put the amendment so effectively
layman's road would stay as it is and
the amendment um
keeps the other speeds at 100 so just so
we're clear all those a favor please say
hi
contrary
clear that lost
council of
meetings councillor stewart
councillor williams
councillor reedman
councillor lackey
council obama
ward
council of duty
mayor gordon no
it's lost 7-3
so back to the original um
uh recommendation uh is there anyone
which just wishes to perspective i think
you've already spoken against lord
that's right
so i'm i'm not gonna unless there's any
further
so do you wish to speak outside is it
yes um i just want to clear them off
clarifying the position and why i
wouldn't know there in the debate and
the reason is that it's all or nothing
for me
i don't believe in what we're doing here
at all and from the people i speak to
they don't either
so that is the reason i voted against
the amendment it's not that i didn't
agree with what most of what was what
was being said but it's either all
nothing for me and uh it's nothing
[Music]
uh did you suspect
i'd just like to say thank you very very
much to the staff of the amount of work
they have put into this this this is
huge
and i really appreciate all their their
work that they've done
okay i don't think there's any further
speakers i'm not going to exercise
around the reply i'll put that all those
in favor please say aye
contrary no declare it carried
i hope you got plenty of those sheets
[Applause]
for the most
most um division sheets we've ever used
in a potion
all right
okay
council atkinson
counselor felix
yes councillor stewart
councillor williams
council redmond
councillor blackie
councillor barney
council award yes council duty yes
mayor gordon yes
it's carried 7-3
right lucky
last so eric um
h uh thank you chief executive for the
division
um
uh h table seven so i'm going to move
that as it is someone prepared to second
that
by count siddiqui
it's not this i've already mentioned
comments at the start around this this
is one that we have had extensive
community feedback
especially from those
who live in that local area concerned
about safety
they've written to us we've met with the
residents
and this is following through with it i
respect that there will be opinions on
both sides of this and i think we've
done our work
um very clearly in this case and i
absolutely support
the recommendation um because we've done
our homework and we've followed good
process so
i see a counselor begging you to speak
am i now supposed to speak
sure
sure
i'd like to
change
let's get this right
to maintain 100 kilometers
from 50 meters past chemwell park
sorry 100 kilometers from 50 meters past
camel park to the current 100 kilometer
an hour sign near skew bridge
so that would also necessitate the
previously passed motion of making it
sixty k's
would also i'd never need to put 60 k's
up to camel park
which was previously passed only to
review the distance back that's a
consequential
the road remains 100 kilometers per hour
from 50 meters past kamwa park
intersection to the current 100
kilometer an hour sign near skewbridge
at the
end
so that's you're meaning flaxton road
would be the first road
and then it becomes skeward's road sorry
that's fine
i understand what you're moving and then
the consequential action of that is that
the 60 kilometer would be extended to 50
meters past
camel park in section so that would be a
note
notes that
that consequential that matter which we
can get tided is i think everyone's
clear on what you're looking to are we
all clear
sure so up to camel park would have to
go to 60 because we previously moved it
to further back 60 then 80.
i'm extending the 60 out to pass camel
park
to make one speed limit change and then
100ks from past 50 meters past camwell
park to the current 100k sign at the
actual skew bridge just which is about
50 meters from the bridge and someone
prepared to stick in there
see
everyone clear on that second about
council williams do you wish to speak
out savannah
thank you
um sorry just speaking to us to test the
meeting and i'm very well aware that
i'll probably lose the vote today
but in all conscience
i am i'm really really disappointed with
how this road
was put in our strategic plans as a
major arterial route
and then we are having constant
feedback from residents on the route
which uh that the speeds are excessive
this road was designed to try and take
some traffic off the lineside road
southbrook road area to help alleviate
condition in southbrook
so the rangiora residents affected by
the congestion and southbrook are also
the views need to be taken into
consideration and in the surveys the the
feedback you can go 30 50 it's around
half and half most residents who would
have submitted on this probably live on
the road and i totally understand their
views i live on 100k road i have drivers
who travel past my my gate 120
kilometers an hour quite frequently so i
am totally in sync with their concerns
with inconsiderate poorly behaved
ignorant drivers who come up and hoot
and cause trouble to those residents who
are trying to access their properties
and i 100 want to keep these residents
safe
but if you come off the skew bridge and
go on to skewbridge road excuse me
excuse me sorry
we just
one speaker at a time
if you come off skewbridge and you come
down to that nice beautiful clear
straight it's got miles of room and
visibility it looks like a hundred k row
i counted how many entrances there were
between that 100k site and chemwell park
where it becomes more of a lifestyle
sort of feeling
um there's 13 properties
and as i said in my two kilometres of
davis road there's 19 properties so
while the traffic is obviously the
factor there's actually less entrances
on many of our other rural lifestyle
roads
so we can't use that as a reason it's
not the entrances that are the problem
the problem is the volume of traffic and
getting gaps
and the speed that some people choose
to travel over a hundred k's along that
road and that again comes back to
enforcement
the speaker today actually made that
comment himself
he said
that the 80-100 will probably make
little difference to be frank
because
that that 100
counts about the debate this thing
the 180 i actually wrote it down i said
it would probably make little difference
if they got hit as a pedestrian on that
road um and i it would make little
difference
um
the road was designed as an arterial
road
and i'm sorry that
to say that we're going to soon have an
east
bypass of rangiora it's 20 to 30 years
away in our plans
20 to 30 years and that is in our
current district plan and current
projections in our district development
strategy
it may accelerate but at this point it's
a long way off
so we have a duty to keep south brook
from becoming completely congested with
our increasing population we need to
encourage people to go around the
western route
and the only way you're going to
encourage them is if it's nothing as
seen as a barrier
putting silver stream 60 has already
been seen as a bit of a barrier
putting this part of the road which is
completely rural with only 13 entrances
it's at
80 will further deter drivers from using
that route and will push them back onto
the hundred kilometer in our line side
road which then further exacerbates our
problems in south brook so we're not
just changing our speed limit today
we're actually affecting all the traffic
patterns of rangiora
and the rural hinterland that it
services
what we're seeing today
an urban
urban we do not want urban majority
always dictating to rural minority how
you look after your minorities in our
district is important
the people who use this road know that
it is safe to travel 100 kilometers an
hour
if they drive responsibly
doing this today will not stop one
irresponsible driver
so what again we are looking at doing
the wrong solution in the wrong area
we're actually detracting from the flow
and effect
to south brook road
if a road looks rural
it should have a rural speed limit
the people on that road are zoned rural
they bought expecting it to be rural and
they also saw the western bypass on
those plans which they knew the traffic
would increase
this is a consequence of our growth it's
not a consequence of the speed limits
so
i'm very very concerned that we have
we've got a kickback response today that
could impact severely on traffic
patterns in rangiora
i really want to encourage people to use
this route and if we don't encourage
them to use this route we're going to
end up with traffic carnage along
southbrook so i cannot in all conscience
vote for it to go down to 80 kilometers
per hour until we have some other
solution to help the traffic movement in
ring era
thank you second to council williams
just to speak
sure councillor atkinson
you look like
again very quickly because we're
taking too long at this i think but the
um but it deserves attention um
look i'm not going to vote for the
amendment i mean the piece from from the
roundabout through to the indecantly
close is rural exactly the argument that
council barnett has been giving us
um why you shouldn't lower a speed limit
to uh to 60k so
you know
i'm afraid
for me it's just the whole damn thing it
just keeps going on and on you know it
doesn't matter which way you lower a
speed limit whether it's in a rural or
whether you don't or you know it's just
nanny state stuff
i'm going to vote against i've already
clearly stated my support for the
original motion
and that's through as i said been out
and speaking with the residents live
there i've stood there
um and watched
their concerns are very valid i agree
entirely with um
councillor atkinson actually that i
think
it'll have the complete reverse effect
if you increase 60 up to camel
park it would it would do exactly what
council banner is suggesting
i think you're the point is being
exaggerated i don't think there's any
evidence this will necessarily the
changes we're looking at will have an
impact online side right we're looking
at south brook we're looking in the long
term future i like council awards
optimism but i'm a realist
we're protecting that land around
a future bypass and we're considering
those options so there are a whole raft
of things
improvements through this corridor will
happen when further when we get the
skewbridge
hopefully replaced and improved so
mr kazani's and others did put the case
well our staff have done their homework
on this
and they've presented a complete package
here that's why it's got my backing for
the original emotion that i'll be voting
against the amendment for the speakers
council means
kristen counselor well i sympathize with
your point of view and i am somebody who
does like to put the pedal to the middle
where i'm allowed
um i do refute the argument that this
would
deter people from taking the flaccid
skewage road
option over sitting in
terrible traffic with several traffic
lights school crossings 50k traffic
slowed down to a crawl
to get to lions side road
if i'm given a choice i'm going to avoid
that urban
crush of traffic at all costs and even
if it is just an 80k road that's fine
it's going to take me 20 seconds more
it's still 20 seconds is nothing
compared to the amount of time that i'm
going to lose on my journey sitting in
the congestion that is self broke at
this moment so
um i'm afraid i'm not going to support
your motion but goodbye
good speakers
uh bad reply counselor sorry oh you
would like to resize yep it's fine
listening to the
debate on this um
might i've also parked on that side of
road there and i've seen
um the key congestion of people getting
in and out of their houses and all that
there's actually nothing to do with
speed it is actually the numbers of cars
on the road and
to be to be quite honest i think this
will actually close the gaps up between
the cars and actually make it worse than
getting in and out of the driveway
and i only supported the camel drive
part because i also went to that meeting
with all the public there a fair
proportion of those people come from
canwell drive because they were
concerned about the hundred k's
and their wee windy road which just does
actually solve that problem for them and
it's one
it has a brush but
this will slow
in my bot it'll congest people together
and it will make congestion worse in
south brook road i've already i've been
surrounding meetings and that drama
and staff have told me if they
um from the satellites by pick and save
if they increase the um that wee bit of
road the zigzag effect all that will
move
people on all that drama or by
congesting this road down to 80 k's is
going to make south brock
more congested of course a lot of people
will turn down fernside road and um
opposite to what you're thinking they're
not going to keep using that road to go
through south well they will turn left
and go down fernside road and
get rid of
the congestion but still there's going
to be a lot of people still carrying on
so it's actually going to close the gaps
up more than anything but as i say
i've gone down the set and i watched the
residency the mean speed of the cars i
think was 91 kilometers in there anyway
when it's fully
ingested
you know they're probably only actually
doing 80 kilometers in there and most of
their time anyway
but
if you slow it up you're going to
actually make that condition worse but
because it's going to be a lot more
cars coming to south brook um
quicker at the same time so um
just
it's not about speed this road it's
congestion for the public that's what i
believe it is completely
and um it doesn't look like an 80k zone
and people are going to speed
with
instance of accidents and all that drama
i've seen a um people going past me and
i've been doing 100 kilometers in there
and they've been probably doing
120 140 climbing giving close to you
five minutes as well i'm sorry that's
cool thank you so just give me the thing
when i met it
thank you very much i am
going to support this motion thank you
um
for the speakers council award and then
you're going to have right reply
councilman because um
people
people coming from
oxford way if they want to trail at 100k
traveling through to christchurch the
best way is done two chain road to tram
mode and continue that's the best
shortest way
to come down
if you want to keep it 100 from campbell
to to
the um through the school bridge
you're going 60 and you're going 100 and
then you're coming into silver stream at
60. so
the argument that there's going to be
traffic backlog
is really
wrong because if we're doing 60 and then
80 and then 60 you're having a much
better flow that's how i see it anyway
and if you want to do 100k and go flat
out
go down to chain road go to tram road
and get to christchurch much quicker
we'd like to exercise a lot of
replacement just just a comment i i
in response counselor atkinson's comment
about 60k i didn't want to go to 60k but
because we took the carpoi tour we
report first and that forced us down to
60k i had no option i couldn't change it
back to 80k which was my preference um
this is actually raised a question on
procedural question on perhaps we should
deal with roads across ward boundaries
quite separately we need to actually
deal it as a separate report because
the person who lives in another part of
the district also has an impact on how
they get from rangora to kaiapoi to
christchurch so it's a traffic pattern
across the district so ward boundaries
actually don't make a lot of sense in
some of these arterial roads and i think
the way we did it unfortunately i
couldn't do that because i had i was i
was bound by the previous mission
um
what i what i wanted to say is that you
know with what i've heard from some of
the people um
we're not looking at the consequences of
this and none of us know what the
consequences of this will actually be
until they happen so it feels like a bit
of a trial to me at the moment and i
think there will be consequences i
wanted to reply to councillor williams
and say yes i believe the gaps will
shorten so be careful what you wish for
because those residents now may see gaps
shortening by traffic
traffic travelling slower
what we will see is probably a bit more
enforcement down there i would say once
it drops to 80 and some perfectly
law-abiding residents will get pinged
with tickets once you get a ticket on a
road you tend to avoid it
so therefore i think if they think oh
well cops hang out there they don't
really hang out on the line side road
because it's a motorway we may as well
go down the line side road
sneak through funsi road which is much
more dangerous than going flaxton road
so i can't tell you exactly what the
consequences are going to be of the
section but i do know it's a wait and
see
um when this passes which i'm sure it
will
i think we'll have to have another
review in six months to make absolutely
i think is noted in report because there
will be consequences and i think those
the residents on that road may not
realise what changing speed limits and
changing
enforcement on roads may actually
produce some results to them and it may
be to their benefit
okay i'll put the amendment
all that's in favor please say aye
against
particularly that lost
so
that's recorded
so then we come back to the um so the
amendment is lost so we come back to the
original
recommendation is there any further
speakers i hope not
um
you're sorry not to watch the curb free
speech but i think we've done this ad
nauseum
um i'm gonna put the recommendation
we're all clear what that is in table
seven
uh
i'll put that all those in favor please
say aye
contrary
to clear that carried
and so
division
divisions to achieve
stuart councillor williams
council redmond
council of lackey
councillor barnett
councillor ward
council of duty here gordon yes
count six three one extension
right so that's carried so that brings
us to the end of
our
speed limit uh consideration they can
acknowledge
as we have done
through the debate our staff ali
gohen
and all those who support them behind
thank you jared as well for your advice
and um it's been a big debate um team so
thank you um thank you all cheer jared
for your attendance as well and
obviously i resent earlier um i think
this is a convenient moment for break
because i know
i've been exercised with this discussion
so
let's have ten minutes be back about ten
to three you grab yourself a cup of
coffee and uh we'll resume
um
with the next agenda generation at that
point thank you
that was not easy
i'm well done thank you
what a big piece of work
it was
oh
um
[Music]
he's
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
tab seven
we're on live stream now thank you so we
resume our meeting so we come to eight
point two pages two six five
two three five seven so tab seven
and diligent so
joey and ellie
thank you and hopefully this report will
be a lot more straightforward than the
previous one
um so the purpose of this is to seek
change the operating time and
of course for the variable speed signs
it's one another school
and low burn school
so this needs to be
mended in our bylaw to align with the
disease notice
um so the
recommendations are included
and it is just the the confirmation of
the will change to the operating time at
the end of the day
the morning remains the same
we're happy to take any questions thank
you any questions
thank you and just a question on these
variables speed signs you know when the
flat is that the flashing ones you're
referring to
how do they when the holiday times how
do they adjust those because i noticed
one
and um
ashley still kept going so this
kept going over the holidays
okay they should be
should be turning them off they
shouldn't be operating over the school
holidays
so we can follow up with the school if
there was a case because they shouldn't
be
so
my question there is
with these two schools will you make
sure that they
adhere to
that
yes and um katie has been in contact
cathy graham has been in contact with
schools already
okay any further questions i've been
indications
yes this is highly sensible to
make sure that these are at the
appropriate time so that people abide by
the regulations and really really
important to keep speed down around the
school times the busy times on our main
roads and so fully in support of this
report
thank you council do you do something i
agree too because it's just so important
the children have a safe time to for
coming to school
and leaving school and that's um and
these signs are a great wonderful
invention thank you
thank you any further speakers
oh i don't think you wish to exercise
write a reply i'll put the
recommendation all those in fact please
say aye
contrary to clearly carried thank you
thanks ellie and joanne
you could stay for the rest of the
meeting if you wish
okay
all right so we now come to 8.3 which is
uh pages 358 to 390. it's a stock
uh rest by law uh request for adoption
so it's lubica
uh and
okay kelly thank you
hello hello how are you you're good
um
[Music]
hopefully we'll read the report i'll
just um give you a couple of bullet
points to start four questions um so we
received 51 submissions for people heard
um we held the hearing on the 22nd of
september
most of the submissions that we got
provided general feedback in terms of
maintenance and flow level of service
rather than specifically referring to
proposed changes in the actual bylaw
and at the hearing the panel determined
that it would be best for drain yourself
to deal with
those type of submissions on a
case-by-case basis so most of them
require
site visits by drainage staff and things
so
that will occur under the resource the
um service request process so we'll log
them and have drainage stuff um go out
the consultation also highlighted that
fact sheets that we have on stock water
aren't referred to or known widely by
customers
and that a level of service and
maintenance responsibilities among other
things are therefore not known widely
either so as a result of the hearing and
the feedback that we received the panel
recommended that staff put together an
information pack that we provide to
existing stock water race users and also
on future limbs so that new owners are
also made aware of
our bylaw their responsibilities our
responsibilities and
it was also suggested that we
write that in conjunction with ecan
staff in order to inform those stock
water race users of the new land and
water regional plans as well
um so yeah that's a summary any
questions
great thank you um libby uh do you want
to add anything kelly
okay so questions uh council stuart
followed by councilman
okay can i just check um just in the
definitions before we do that
circulates this report to our community
boards
and it's the mark so this is the moving
signal might be one of the way it's the
mahi tahi
joint development committee
and a liaison committee i think is the
correct terminology and he's just
missing an own boards from being fussy
so right okay so um we're going to move
council stuart did you have a question
yes so
councilman
so just just a question overall i just i
was a bit confused about the
responsibility for excluding stock from
waterways
from ecan and ourselves and how clearly
that's defined in the bylaw what has
been done in the bylaw to improve
who does what in terms of that which at
the moment is not really being followed
up very often
so we've added an explanatory note to
refer users to the land and water region
plan but we were conscious of not
wanting to
overlap or kind of re-quote rules
because if we did that if he can ever
change this and we'd have to review our
bylaw um and also because
waimakariri district council staff don't
enforce their can rules it wasn't
appropriate to include them directly but
that is part of the reason why the
information pack kind of come about as
well because
it was thought that
you know you're not finding all that
information in one place so it might be
challenging for users to kind of locate
all of the different rules and things if
we collate it in conjunction with ecam
then hopefully it will make it easier
for them to understand
what they have to do
so kelly is there a risk if we put an
information pack with our logo on it
that people will see as being our
responsibility and that we're actually
enforcing it
possibly i think the role that we see
ourselves playing is very much in that
education and informative space
if there are issues we will still
proactively respond to them and we see
ourselves as the first point of call and
if it gets to a point where it needs to
be escalated that's where we will be
working with ecan from an enforcement
perspective
okay
further question did you have a question
counselor or you
okay so no if you have a question
counselor meanings i don't know if it
makes any difference but if we pass it
as it is um is it gonna be proofread
because i just there's an error in here
um
uh
on on the bylaw as is written on page
373
clause 5.4.2
it says all such material deposited by
the council land or its agent is to be
placed in accordance with clauses 5.3.1
5.3.3 and 5.3.3
so it's supposed to be 5.3.2 and i don't
know if that makes any difference if we
pass it like that
or not but if if it does then maybe we
should just change that you get the
goldfish
i want the chocolate fish
no um
and also am i understanding correctly
that those that
don't
use the
stock water race
but have it
alongside their property must
[Music]
still clean and prevent blockage and
remove at their own cost and
what does it say um
basically if they don't use it but it
goes past the house they have to keep it
clean at their cost and
they bear responsibility for the clinics
just
clarifying that okay all right so you're
um so it's been moved so i've taken this
down for your questions moved by council
stuart second of council blacky jewish
to speak as a student
thank you i will briefly only three
minutes i've got um
well you can have up to 10 for these yes
but
keep it to three would be much
appreciated sorry and i will
correct um circulating the report to the
community buds while we may have some i
think it's meant to be our boards but
look um this was a robust and and to my
i think the panel degree an overdue
process and we had
uh we had 50 over 50 submissions and it
was clear um as we consider the
submissions um that there is confusion
out there about responsibilities
um there was confusion with the
operation of the irrigation races um
as this from the stock water race um
and
as you you can see but from the analysis
of the submissions the issues that um
have
come up i mean it is
an indication to staff that work needs
to be done and that was the genesis of
suggesting that we put an information
package that goes out to all property
owners with a race through
their property even if
[Music]
they don't use it
then
some of the benefits of
not using it for stock is that
that
property owners can apply in writing to
the council to use it for domestic
irrigation on their property now that
wasn't well known at all in fact there
are only about 20 or 30 i think
out of the 1500
properties that have race going through
that that do that
so
there is general um
a general need for upping the
communication improving also the um
the language of the by-law so it is not
um
not um stuck in in language that is long
long past its used by a date
so i mean i um commend it
to
you to um give it the tick off and it
has been
apart from the literals that
that council meetings has identified it
is it has been a robust process that we
have
[Music]
given good scrutiny to and because of
the crossover with
particularly on the stock exclusion
issues
and that we do need to work with
with ecan on that and
people with property owners with the
race going through
their properties need to understand that
even if they're using it for stock water
the stock cannot access
the
water race at all so there needs to be a
trough system that takes it back
from
them
putting their feet
in the race and having a poop which they
do do
so that's
essentially what
the canterbury land and water
regional plan will
will do
um
very keen that we do a comprehensive
communications package out to
um
[Music]
to property owners as i said and you can
see by the analysis of this admissions
there's clear misunderstandings that we
have the real opportunity to address
so commend um
and and i must thank the staff um for
you know going over above with this
well done libby it was it's um it was
very comprehensive and i think i'm
really happy with the place you too
kelly thank you
um i'm really happy with where we've got
with it and i i want it to be um as i
think the rest of the panel are really
easy to use and understand
by law and
acknowledge that a communications
information package um essential to
making sure that happens
so commend your appro to your approval
thank you uh councillor blackhead used
to add anything
just very briefly it was a good process
um and thank you to lillian the staff um
yeah
in an overarching sort of a way there
was quite quite a discussion and and we
haven't resolved it because it wasn't
our remit to do so about that picking up
on what the question nikki asked the
responsibility and the liabilities of
people who have a race on their land
they never use or have a race on the
roadside which is not their property
passing them and they never use and one
day we're going to have to sit down and
address that but that wasn't our it
wasn't our job this time around i just
foreshadow that because it's quite a
problem
i just um just thank the panel for the
work that you've done putting into this
it's overdue and and
i'm sure it will be much appreciated i
think it's an excellent suggestion to
have an information pack to go out to
property owners because increasingly
uh over the years i've had many
approaches from people who have no idea
what it means to them where it goes
through them what their obligations
or their rights are so
i think that's a really good um
suggestion um i agree our staff in this
space do excellent work so thanks libby
kelly and team um much appreciated a few
of the speakers
uh counter duty
it was very i was actually delighted to
be part of this
committee
this
stock water is such a significant and
historical part of our waimakariri's
history and it's really important that
people that have this stop water race
running through there understand the
significance of it it's um
it was a life
line
back uh when it was first introduced
about 1896
and um it's it's a live line for for
farmers back in that day and and um
but just and they just need to
understand just how important that piece
of infrastructure is so
i would really like to see some
information go out to them just
help them to understand what that piece
is all about thank you
thank you
for the speakers council meetings
i'd just like to say thank you to the
panel and the stuff for um dragging what
was a pretty clunky looking old bylaw
kicking and streaming into the 21st
century
it reads a lot better now and it's a lot
more clear i very much welcome the
approach of educating those who have
these stock water races go through their
properties because there is very little
understanding and as you are aware i do
deal with very much
in the lifestyle block
area if you will and
there isn't a lot of knowledge i think
amongst people as to what their right
and obligations are
with any kind of waterway and what the
difference is between them and you know
whether it's drain or a stock water race
etc so i think that some education um
being put together and put out to those
people would be a very very welcome
addition to
the information that we've got already
available
but um thank you for your work everyone
and i do support the motion
to the speakers
write reply if you'd like councillor
stuart i'll put the recommendation all
those available please say aye
contrary to clear that carried great
thank you libby and kelly
so
uh 8.4 is next which is the rengar
renewals budget for church street so
that's colin
391-394
thanks khan
good afternoon
so um i'll try to be brief with this
report um so this we withdrawing care of
water renaults we had a
core program of work which have been
designed tended and ordered
but this report is about
another piece of work that was
identified um
through the design of a sewer main job
so with the um central ranking or a
stage five
sewer job
the designer identified that they were
going
past a water lane that was due for
renewal
as well so suggested
including that design for the wood of
maine as part of the sewer contract
um which makes sense because it
minimizes disruption and um should
provide some savings in terms of traffic
management and other costs
so we got that priced and the um the
price came back in 160 thousand dollars
so what we're proposing is that they
that we bring forward 170 000 from next
year's water watermelon renewals budget
into this year
so that we can award a separable portion
for the water
um
portion of work on church street into
the wrangura sewer contract
and the contractors already priced that
as a proportion throughout their
contract so
they've been awarded the bulk part of
the contract and are just waiting to
hear it from us on the award of the
piece of work which they would complete
in april in may subject to
us ordering it to them so i'm happy to
take any questions on that
thanks colin any questions
it's a recommendation someone prepared
to move moved council william seconded
council award
um
do you wish to speak count swims
i think it makes common sense doing it
all in one hit rather than a lot of
double disruption so thank you
i guess award
for the speakers
put the record
yourself um i'll put the recommendation
all those favor please say i
can't clear that carry thank you colin
all right so uh next uh 8.5
pages
395-454 the property acquisition
disposal policy rob
thank you
it's uh
and once i'm happy to invite members of
the working group if they wish to end
any comments after rob's site
good afternoon mr councillors and staff
this report takes adoption of the draft
acquisition and disposal policy
commonly referred to as paired
and attached to attachment one
this has been developed with the
guidance and support of the property
acquisitions disposal working group
which includes five councillors
the policy think to ensure fair
transparent and compliant processes and
behaviours are in place to protect the
rights of property owners and council's
reputation while endeavour to maximize
return from any property acquisitions or
disposal act
with the core purpose of the
organizations critical however the
opportunity and funny
keeping unidentified or underutilized
of an asset or service that is needed
elsewhere
the policy establishes a regular
three-year review of council's property
holdings by prospective activity asset
owners within council sectors green
space with orders
and others
and the initial process uses an
assessment that identifies properties
that are well utilized and fit for
purpose in relation to their primary
activity
for those properties they don't score
the assessment
value a more detailed assessment um of
the personnel for retaining the property
for the current useful purpose
and this may give rise
also
release powerful site for repurposing
the review
august of this year
if i need to get rob another mic because
it just keeps going in and out
okay
i might need to get that looked at for
the next few days because
it's we've been having a few issues with
that so maybe i don't know adrian who
looks after that one on the team
is that better yeah i have this right
only a little bit more on the
introduction
the um
the initial list of properties would
allow a program of more detailed
assessments to be undertaken by the
activity unit and property unit
to consider the merit of retention
repurposing or disposal
delivery on the initial assessment
however may be challenging for some
activity areas in particular green space
due to the large number of properties
under their management which is over 500
as a result the property unit will work
with s owning units to triage list of
properties under review
as a result there may be some properties
that will not be reviewed prior to your
estate due to the low likelihood of
change of use or a viable sale prospect
being progressed
those properties are not reviewed over
the next six months will be included in
a review for the following 12 to 18
month period
details of the program will be expanded
on in the pad working group
to ensure appropriate prioritization and
oversight is taken into account
uh an example of that
is the intended focus on three waters
given the potential changes involved in
that sector
i'll take the balance of the report um
as being read in the policy
and open to questions thank you
or any other members of the panel what
to add
chair of the page yeah
very quickly just to say look this this
policy has been through the mill
it's been there and back then it went
there and back again and it's since been
there and back again
solicitor's eyes over it staff's eyes
over it wherever we can put the eyes
over it we've done that to try and come
up with a policy
that is
hopefully understandable
in a pretty complicated world when it
comes to uh
property that's owned by a council on
the steps you have to take to actually
get rid of it or buy it whichever way it
may be and how we can
uh such things as reacting
quickly when things come up and
owners want to dispose things pretty
quickly it's it's actually really hard
to do
so what i just want to reassure
councillors of is that
the committee has um to get to this
point and get a
get this in front of you has been
through the mill pretty much and jihan i
want to thank him rob and his staff for
uh
for their input it's been um it's been
valuable to actually get somewhere where
we need to
uh we need to actually get out there and
make sure that we've got it right the
only real way to do that is on the
advice of the people that have given us
that we have it correct
thank you any other panel members want
to add
all right thank you so questions uh
casabana
yes rob i'm just a bit curious about how
council's community outcomes rank in
terms of the priorities on some of these
other sections so on page 406 of our
agenda
which
is in your section three policy
objective
in point i you've got aligned with
council's policy strategies
but you've kind of got the council's
community outcomes at the bottom is kind
of a little add-on wouldn't it be better
to put the council's community
outcomes with the council policies
strategies long-term plans and can you
explain why that wasn't done
i'm not sure that um it was necessarily
rationalized quite the way that you're
doing talking through
and and the the timing and sequencing of
that i don't think necessarily takes
away from
the significance or relevance or
importance
of those matters
um so i'm not sure if that really
adequately answers the
question um
but uh i
i do see really community outcomes are
the driver
um
albeit that community outcomes also
are subject to change over the course of
time as well
as are policies and strategies
just following up on that b3 one of the
criteria sections doesn't actually
clearly seem to clearly mean community
could that be strengthened
it's certainly open to strengthening
that if that is
is considered
by certainly the other members of
the working group
may have some views and thoughts on that
i would like to make the point that
the review process
is actually an initial step it's not the
end point
it's only a means by which we identify
some properties that
may in the word may as not will
be
considered further for repurposing or or
disposal
in the process
at that point is
very much a thorough exploration of the
community
value that is placed on the existing
asset and activity that goes with it
so
i guess from
there are some aspects of that that are
sequential uh and that then are covered
um at that later point in in more depth
and just finally i just wonder
have you had any feedback from the
community boards
and if not why aren't they consulted
before we adopt this policy
um noting on
4.1418 it's only council that's involved
not community boards
this process
i i think that um
i'm certainly open to the other panel
members or the working group members
will also comment on that um it wasn't
something that came up as we were
pulling this together however what i
would say is is again there's an
internal
if you like a technical process here and
part of the consultation around any
change
of use of a property
or disposal of a property would
certainly be something that
i would imagine if the community board
as a stakeholder
they would likely to be engaged with
and i think what we have to realize is
these aren't necessarily driven by the
property unit
all of these sites have got an activity
owner who themselves engage with
relevant stakeholders including the
community board
so consideration of any changes like
that
would
in all likelihood go through quite a
thorough process around
the views of those stakeholders
okay
do you want anything
i am happy to add to that the the rob's
extension is actually a very good one um
and then the intention is the community
woods that
um
would have a a say in any matter in any
property within the area that that would
happen but first it has to go through
that rigorous profit process of can we
or can't we
and that's that's the idea of this
policy is if we can sell it for instance
do we want to and and the real matter
that
that was
a challenge for all of us is how do we
get that in the first instance to every
department
of this organization
because just because green space wants
to get rid of it
doesn't mean to say that roading doesn't
want it or
water or whomever that may be and that
our understanding is a committee and the
committee can correct me if i'm wrong
that that has actually always been a
challenge
people have put
some ground across people's tables that
they don't particularly want but it
may not have gone to other places so
it's about
where it can go in the organization and
how
and then from there if there is a
disposal or an acquisition
then it's how
that gets to
obviously everybody else including
community boards and community about
what it is that we do
that is the intention of this policy
as i said before i think
we have to sort of test it to make sure
um before the review that we we do have
it right we're pretty convinced we are
sheehan our solicitor is pretty
convinced that we have it correct and he
made several changes
um
and
so i'm hoping
that you know through the test we have
got right if we haven't i don't think
there's any real harm to be done
to us but the community was certainly
the uh
the start of the conversation if you
like so
okay
there's any questions do you wish to
move uh policy mr uh
kenneth rankinson
seconded by councillor redmond
do you wish to speak
well i think i've probably done that
another effect of explaining what it is
that we've done but again just reiterate
to uh uh certainly xian who has had
um
opened our eyes a couple of times with
some things that we thought we could do
but couldn't do without a process around
it it's not like
heading out and just selling your
business
privately
and there are some certain things from
indication of properties for sale that
that
can actually almost hamstring us from
selling them um if we don't do it in the
correct manner so
hence the reason for this policy and
hopefully
hopefully we've got it right and that
that it works well for this
organisation as a whole and everybody
within this organisation including the
community can have someone put into that
thank you
thank you mr mayor
i'd just like to thank robin his team
for the work that went into this um i
started off thinking we were going to
have a disposable sort of working group
but it sort of morphed into something
much more than that
and we have spent a lot of time on the
policy and i think we've ended up a
pretty good document
and it's
not a simple matter to dispose of
property there are so many and
a multitude of different types of
ownerships or restrictions and
can of worms really so i'd get very
frustrated if i was working with it
every day we're also you're doing well
so i'm i'm just happy to um support the
adoption of the policy
council
yes and just to say that i will support
the policy my questioning was just
around the strengthening of community
and just where our community outcomes it
in relation to community policy because
i think outcomes come first and policy
comes second you drive your policy from
your outcomes so i felt it should have
higher precedence actually in the policy
but i'm not going to die it's the first
time i've got this um i'm just aware
that sometimes community are very
attached to council assets or to council
land and have used it for various
purposes which may or may not be
particularly aware in the council um
particularly rural areas
and we have you know whether it's road
reserve whether it's building it's
really really hard to get a
comprehensive posse that would go from
unformed roads to parks to buildings i
mean i i really applaud you guys for
putting something together that covers
everything um but i just
i am nervous because we had an example
recently where our district is small
people talk as soon as there's
investigation into a property it gets
known and then the chinese whispers
starts i just wanted to make sure that
we're getting the community outcomes
right first before we go on to the
policy
okay further speakers
right reply
well just around there and i think the
example you give is actually very real
the reality is
that until there is an indication that a
property is either going to be disposed
of or
or bought
there is nothing
and
that is actually the message that needs
to get out of out because of legal
implications
while i have absolutely no problem with
bolstering the strength of communities
in there because that's our objective
but the reality is
that um we have to go through
almost a hell of a process before we get
to the point of talking to people is it
or isn't it why is it does anyone want
it all those things because
at the start of that it may not be any
good to anyone either way um it's
actually going through their policy to
get
something to put in front of it's a bit
of chicken and egg but it's put in front
of the community you ask what it is
that they require us to do so
yeah that's it's sort of a
so i understand your question um it's
just that it is it can be quite
complicated to do
so
thank you i'm going to put the
recommendation all those in favor please
say aye
contrary to clear that carried thanks
rob thanks team
okay um 8.6 the kaipoi community hub
project management for sasha enabling
works we had a
reasonably good briefing about this this
morning so
it follows on next part of the process
so thanks tessa and chris
[Music]
good to go thank you
um the key purpose of this report is to
seek council approval that 100 000 of
the 300 000 provision from the covert 19
recovery fund
approved at january 2021 meeting of
council be allocated for project
management to ensure effective and
efficient completion of site enabling
works for the
kaiapoi community hub project
and obviously that is pending
confirmation of funding approval to
progress the
project via the annual plan process
uh you will now all be very familiar
with this project and aware that funding
has been confirmed through the long-term
plan to develop the charter street land
for a community hub where recreational
and hobby groups can co-locate and where
people can be welcomed connected learn
and develop new skills
in presenting this report i'd like to
highlight that this site is included in
the waimakariri residential with zone
recovery plan for rural land uses
part of the site was included in the
kaiapoi reserve's master plan as a
community studio and the activity was
insulted on through the 2021 annual plan
this project has received significant
support from kai poi to ahi community
board alongside broad-spectrum community
stakeholder and high-level funder
endorsement
attached to the report you will see a
summary of work done in response to
initial community
consultations which were quite extensive
the draft final concept land that rachel
and duncan presented earlier today
and
the purpose and objectives for the trust
some preliminary work on that
and
the
proposed kaipoi hub development
structure and that includes the
community and social development for the
project alongside the proposed
infrastructure project development
um significant work has been undertaken
to date
uh with the project gaining considerable
and and perhaps even unprecedented
momentum
community development staff have
undertaken
a considerable work to ensure the
viability and sustainability for the
proposed hub
this has centred as rachel detailed on
the establishment of a trust with sound
governance process and operating models
including a broad spectrum and long-term
funding strategy to support the ongoing
operation of the hub
long-term sustainability and future
briefing have been key considerations
right from the start
while in all likelihood the trust will
own all the buildings on site
all three current user groups satisfy
food rescue pro k and men's shed
agree that a shared and uniform approach
will address many of the communities
concerns
maximise funding opportunities and
enable them to get on with their core
business
as indicated support for this project
including the facilities
aspects
has
been indicated by key funders like
lotteries and writer foundation
in consultation with the three user
groups trustee has now been drafted
this has been submitted for review by
council's legal advisor
terms of reference will be finalized by
the user groups as part of the trust
establishment once the draft deed has
been reviewed
a detailed draft
set of user guidelines has also been
developed
this was done quite early on
it has since been reviewed this will be
utilized by the board of trustees to
frame the operation management and
maintenance of the facility
so with sound governance and operational
infrastructure planning in place there
is now an urgent need to ensure that the
site a enabling infrastructure works
have adequate project management
provision to see the initial development
through to its completion
you will note that in a report to the
january 2021 council meeting staff
flagged the potential
need four hundred thousand dollars to
see enabling work development through to
this point
at its january meeting
in 2021 council adopted the
recommendation to allow provision of 300
000 from the covert 19 recovery fund
toward the potential resourcing of
social recovery facilitation and
infrastructure project management for
the kayak hub
along with any potential impacts on
aquatic facilities subject council
approval and this set alongside
covert recovery funding allocation for
economic development
for
2022-23 annual
deliberations
staff have made provision to retain the
existing mainstream community
development role
given the ongoing impact covert 19 on
our rapidly growing district before
community development staff do not
anticipate needing to utilise the
cauvery over recovery fund for the 2020
to 23 financial year for those aspects
particularly social recovery
which is now ongoing
alongside this low uptake
for the fund
um has predominantly been due an ex to
an unexpectedly low impact of covert on
the local economy and there are no law
there
and there's no longer a need for aquatic
facilities to utilise a fund
so taking into account the 30 000
allocated toward a disaster recovery
strategy review
at this current point only 800 000 of
the 2.1 million has been utilized and i
will review you to
a table
as item 4.2 for a breakdown of actual
expenditure of the fund date
infrastructure in sight works is now
planning is now complete
and as i've indicated strong governance
community
development led project management for
the social and community aspects is in
place however there is currently no
provision for project management for the
site enabling works
staff have now developed a draft final
concept plan and you saw that this
morning and ready to
progress this to
resource consent
the original concept plan was revised in
response to feedback from residents
meetings
and
workshops and continued consult
consultation with the proposed hub
groups and technical and practical
considerations for the site
staff were successful in obtaining 4
435 000 from council through the
2021 to 31 long-term plan and this
funding is split between the earthquake
recovery loan and the recreation loan
and i know that you were updated on this
earlier
and this has been included in the
long-term plan budgets however as
identified in previous reports the
funding approved in the long-term plan
will not be sufficient to fully develop
the kaiapoi community hub in its
entirety
and strategically looking to address
this staff have worked extensively with
the hub user groups to ensure that the
concept design is as cost effective as
possible
the red zone regeneration project is
nearing completion
and a corresponding restructure of the
district regeneration team has resulted
in the non-replacement of key staff
leading the technical aspects of the
community hub product and some of you
may remember michelle flanagan
had a key role in this in the initial
stages
so what this means is there is currently
no one dedicated to project manage the
infrastructure related aspects of the
project including the site enabling
works
externally contracted project management
will be necessary to ensure that this
work is completed
a timely and cost effective fission
it is anticipated that such provision
will be required from february 2021
through until the end of the
2022-23 financial year
that's approximately 16 months
at a cost of 1470
per week over a 68 week period equating
to just under the 100 000
anticipated um
project management cost for the
infrastructure
aspects of the community hub
so you will note that this report
proposes three options
option one being to approve the request
to
utilize an external project manager
and to use the funds from the
covert recovery fund to you to do so
option two
is to decline the request and have staff
resource this through the acquisition of
external funding this is the the least
favored option
um and funding streams are
asking us for staffing
we already have a highly stretched
social and
mental health and community sector
and uh it's very unlikely that we are
going to get project management costs
for a project such as this out of those
usual funding streams
and this would also cause significant
delay
and that would result in
a really detrimental effect on the good
will and support of major funders
p community partners
and also
uh community residents who do have an
expectation at this point that the team
is i think i think your points are very
well understood you've made them really
well
so i just want to wrap up yeah we can go
to questions because
it's pretty comprehensive what you're
looking for so i'm really clear
is there any questions uh council
williams follow the council award
yeah well we've been concerned we've all
been told covet is just going to be
starting and we haven't used much of fun
yet but it's
potentially going to be starting how can
this be covert related compared with
northbrook
community hub there what's the
difference what should we actually be
using the covered money
when covert actually hasn't struck our
community big time yet as predicted
okay so
the kai koi community was severely
impacted by the first covert event in
2020
the local primary schools had a
significant increase in families who
could not afford to buy food
they set up
food bank
relationships where there were food
puzzles delivered for pres for parents
breakfast clubs and lunches for children
so
there was a significant loss of income
in a number of families across kaiapoi
particularly secondary income
which in a lot of families is what
determines whether you can pay the rent
the mortgage and food
thank you
further questions count
i i think it was addressed councillor
williams but if you have a third
question you're welcome to put it
council award
thank you tessa um it is complex but um
we had this briefing this morning and i
made some notes so i'd like to sort of
get to the chase if i can
um because i am actually another person
um i understand that we've already um
approved 465 000 from last year and
there's a hundred thousand dollars
uh for site and car parking that's been
approved
and there's some other money coming in
which totals
and eighteen thousand dollars the cost
to do this new vamped one is to is
one
we're looking at 1.3 million we're 635
000 short
and that's what
we need to look at to get this underway
to get the basis to get it completed
which includes a 25 contingency is that
really the bones of it no so so this
morning's report referred to the request
for
uh the project development costs right
so that's the cost of the of the
infrastructure
side of the development what this report
seeks and it is confusing what this
report seeks is project management
provision
to make sure that that infrastructure
project is delivered effectively and
efficiently so this is on top of
that it's 100 000 on top of the 635 000
yes so because make sure that that could
be project managed right and delivered
on time yes okay i'm with you all right
so we're looking at six thirty five
thousand dollars
okay thank you further questions
well um some of you need to move
uh move council awards second account
sir plaggy
do you wish to speak dance award um yes
i think that um it's a much needed
hasn't got anything like this and i
think it's quite timely
given that the men's shed is you know
there's a disaster that devastation has
happened last weekend and i think i
understand this three to six months um
lead and i think we need to get on with
the job we need to get it done i think
it'd be amazing uh for the community of
kaapoi and
i think we have a responsibility to um
to give them
give them this award would uplift and
create
a lot of space for a lot of people in
the community of kawai
kazupaki
we need to proceed with this keep the
momentum going yes there are going to be
lots of hurdles to jump
in this project
financial i'm referring to
i'm confident we can reallocate we can
reallocate some regen money we can tap
into the funding sources
yeah it's going to be it's going to be
tough to get the money together but i'm
sure we can do it and it also could be
tough with the inflation factor that's
going to hit us as well but we'll
cross that bridge when we come to it in
the meantime we need this 100k to keep
keep the project rolling please support
it thank you further speakers
council williams
whilst i think this is a good thing for
a community hub there
i do have concerns about
us spending great powers money um
well there could be potentially a bit of
a downturn in our community and people
may have problems suffering
paying just normal rates bill and we are
seen be adding to it all the time i
realize it's a good community
facility but
outside funding is my behavior rather
than tracking ratepayers money at it all
the time because some of those rate
paths are struggling and are probably
going to be struggling worse off soon
with what potentially could happen in
the
code situation so
whilst i'll be supporting it i am very
concerned if
we're just spending money
in situations where some of the rate
powers
are struggling
[Music]
councillor williams said but i i you
need to spend so you need to we need to
augment this project and do it properly
it's been shown to have widespread
support i think a team have done the
work on that it's really impressed with
rachel's
duncan's presentation here this morning
and we've been through a full community
development model here from the
views that were expressed at the first
meeting we went to to seeing the concept
to
then going out and meeting people on
site it's been very well done um i fully
support it's an awesome community
project and you know last weekend was
clearly demonstrated that the absolute
need for this and how vulnerable some of
these groups are recognize the comments
you make we need to spend it on the make
a dollar in the sense that there will be
as chris mentioned this morning there
will be or i think it was grant there
will be um
it has been approaches to rata and the
other groups they are waiting for this
to come together and
i was pretty
very impressed by the reaction that was
expressed today that clearly indicates
that this is a project that will carry
their support for funding uh it's
already got msd funding behind it which
is
almost unheard of so um and certainly
world's life been in the past so it's
proving itself so well done my full
support
level
thank you
is question but i mean um some of these
facilities are not just high voice
satisfied certified few uh foods doesn't
just work with the kai boy
but it desperately needs a home
in trying times to make sure that it can
can do something and i think it can all
be rest assured around this
this table that a project of this nature
wouldn't even be being thought about if
there wasn't regeneration land
um because i'm not sure where we would
have it or how we could actually set it
up
um and somewhere else in cairo the
borders are pretty stretched
now that land is there and um
it needs a really good use and in my
view this is probably one of the best
uses you can give that land i mean
the other argument enough by the
residents when
things were pretty hot was turn it back
into housing
um so that was uh there was an
interesting interesting concept from
in fact almost from a couple of people
who said we never want to see housing on
here again so it was rather interesting
in itself but what i'm saying is that
land is the basis of this
the community is the basis of the
project the fact we have the land means
we can actually do something with the
project and that's for me the important
thing and yes it costs money in which to
do that but our mirror is right we
have to speculate to accumulate and that
is more than the dollar it is about
people's well-being
mr speakers council
yes i wasn't going to speak i'm fully in
support of the project but um i just
want to also note that it's a it's a
very very small investment for what
we're seeing in terms of food security
in the district and that to me is the
most important project on this whole
community hub the risks are helped but
that's the one that has to go ahead um
we're already seeing food inks now
struggling and it's it's it's only it's
only february now we're going to have to
go through potential shortages of supply
with covered
and it's absolutely essential that we
find a base that's going to be suitable
and appropriate
for the food the food supply we're going
to need to do going forward so to me
that's actually why it's really really
critical to get this project up and
running um so we if we ever have
disasters in the future as well that we
can look after industry
thank you uh write a reply council award
i'd just like to
be aware that the down northbrook road
the the community hub there that we have
there is so utilized it's so well
it's it
is
does a a lot for our young people
it's very very busy
it's well used and it's a very important
part of the development of our young
people um so i can see this
hub in this area and copy doing
that and more
for the people of kanpur and the people
of tuahue or whatever whoever and for
the whole district and i see that it's
going to be a wonderful asset
for that for our district
thank you we're going to put the
recommendation
all those in favor please say aye
contrary i declare that carrick thanks
tears from chris
right um next we've got the cheers
report so i found out this morning that
um jia's
process had been considered that cheers
didn't need to come along in future i've
asked that cheers are invited to come
and present their reports
because i think that's important for
them to have that opportunity to speak
to us if they'd like to so
but with that in mind i'm just going to
i think we'll take the lot on lock
because there's no real need to
um debate them individually as people
want to you're happy to move council
savannah
by um council williams
you know what do you wish to speak
uh no further speakers i'll put those
reports all those in favor please say
aye
contrary to clear they're carried in
just in doing that just to acknowledge
the work that the community boards do
and we very much value their involvement
and it's good to see that reporting back
here
so next is
referred from committees item 99.1 so
that's don
thank you
uh pages four nine two to five
um one night so
donald jr thank you
thank you mr mayor i will take this uh
mata as read i think everybody around
the table will be very familiar with
this topic
uh however it is important to note this
is quite an important milestone in this
particular
project
the effect of passing this resolution
will be to adopt the concept plan
as has been circulated previously
and it will also be
to establish a south brook road
reference group for moving the long-term
elements
forward
the terms of reference have been
discussed firstly with the south brook
road working group
and also with the ring europe advisory
community board so there is general
support
for all of the recommendations in here
and i'll leave it at that and allow
happy to take any questions thanks do
you want to anything
um i'm happy with that okay thank you
questions yes
so do we summer prepared to move see the
hand going up council lackey
you're gonna
count the wards seconded uh do you wish
to speak council award
no we've been we've a lot of planning a
lot of consultation and it's time to
move and i'm sure that the southport
residents will be very strong see
something happening
so well done
any further speakers
i'll put the recommendation then all
those in favor please say aye
contrary to clear they're carried on and
jerk thanks for your work and nothing
behind that cheers
right um next is 9.2 cup ford grant
um pages five twenty to five three nine
ranger croco club so this is just a
recommendation that's come from cnr
thank you
that was going to happen um so martin
please stand
please rise for the council
um
um i'll let martin introduce himself
then soon as you've put them forward
um thank you grant and everybody for the
opportunity um yeah my name is martin
mcgregor so i'm the new senior advisor
for community recreation uh just it's my
same day um i come to you from the
christchurch city council where i work
for 13 years um i live in pegasus um so
i've got rid of the commute so that's uh
yeah very pleasing but yeah forward to
seeing a lot more of you
welcome and it's great to have you with
us thank you
and i see you followed the tradition of
thai tuesday is it yes
he was told it was not optional
good work thanks chris thank you um
thanks martin uh just in terms of the
report that you've got in front of you
there as the mayor pointed out this has
been to
um
community and recreation a couple of
times first through a deputation by the
club and then secondly through a report
that we presented back in december
i'll take the report
as read
the underlying theme here that we're
looking for from the council is that we
actually resolve
to request the working group that's been
proposed to set up um that the ring
you're a pro k club do pay back the loan
um so that's the kid that's the key
decision they're actually asking the
council to ratify here
so thank you i'll take any questions
casa redmond
ah thank you grant um there are two
differences between the cnr report and
the recommendation of 9.2
both refer to 42 000
one is silent on interest the report
today says 42 000 including interest
would you agree that should be plus
interest
is the starting point
yes and that was actually debated at the
cnr meeting as well from what i from i
recall um council redmond so yeah i
would agree
thank you uh further questions
you prepared to move the recommendation
to council reading with that edition
well he's sickened by council lebron
um
wish to speak
uh just the same as amir that this was
thrashed out at cnr it's not an easy
topic to deal with
and hopefully the working party will
perform a miracle thank you
thank you
counselor brian do you wish to speak
and you can respond to yourself if
you're like cancer edmond but what the
recommendation all those favor please
say i
contrary cleared carriage
9.3 going to handle that grunt [ __ ]
as andy oh sorry i didn't see andy there
pardon me must have just snuck in
unless you've been sitting there for a
while just to see you
perfect timing so uh 9.3 uh 540 to 554
ranger town hall hello everybody um
so you might need to use the by you
don't have to leave your face mask on
unless you want to india it's entirely
up to you
yeah
yeah i need to put public and i'll get
hot and flustered underneath it as well
so
i'll leave it on it
so yes we are looking at uh replacing
the retractable seating it's currently
in cinema 3 in the rangiora town hall
and replacing it for a 98 plus fixed
solution more in line with the existing
cinemas one and two
um the purpose of this report today is
obviously
for
the castle to recommend the expenditure
of 150 000 to be up for consideration in
the 2020-23
annual plan um on the basis that
the money will be loan funded with
payback arranged for an increase in base
rent to rank at town hall summers
of approximately an increase to seventy
thousand one hundred and forty thousand
our current commission rate that we get
from all their ticket sales will remain
the same so in in essence it will be
loan funded and it should obviously
not be an impact on the rate payer this
is will be arranged over a 10-year
period
um
i think most or most people have seen
the report so i will probably take it
that it's been rest um and open up for
questions thank you
jim and i discussed this morning with uh
adrian to some adjustments to the
recommendation which was
oh thank you is it is it on diligent or
not quite
so just the recommendation we'd read
it's just just a couple minor things
recommends the expenditure of 150 000
for consideration we've put the word
draft in your plan in there because
it's draft until we approve it so draft
annual plan subject to manager finance
and business support and manager
community and recreation receiving an
appropriate three-year business
operations forecast
to predicted participation
of projected
participation so that's a different
projected participation and revenue from
town hall cinemas to be reported back to
council i know that that's come in but
that
what had been discussed at management
was that those two managers would get
together and um
and and consider that
and then that would be reported back to
us once it's been so it's effectively
this is giving a green light subject to
that being properly concerned perfect is
it okay that's absolutely fine yeah you
should have had an updated report a
three-year forecast from tehman cinemas
yesterday
yes so that what this is asking for
subject to colleagues agreeing is that
our senior managers review that
obviously with us with yourselves
perfect to make sure that that's in line
and
they're
in line because we've we've had a number
of instances where
um they've asked for
relief rightly so in the process but we
just want to make sure that it's viable
if we're spending a hundred and fifty
thousand
yeah okay so do members understand their
questions
just a question of you mr mayor
why would we recommend the expansion now
and we're also discussing in two days
time the annual plan wouldn't that be
the most appropriate time to actually
talk about the expenditure
um well it's recommending the
expenditure for consideration in the
draft plan that's what the word says but
it's saying that we as a council
recommend to ourself that we spend it
whereas the wording could be just
recommended council to consider the
expenditure yeah i think that's trying
to change the wedding recommends council
i'm not the sole decision maker here um
[Music]
wendy sorry
you'll move that so you're happy with
that change wendy
seconded council atkinson would you like
to speak quesadilla yes i'm actually
very thrilled that we're going to be
looking at this
draft deal plan
um i just it's an opportunity to really
promote and and enhance our
our um
films
investment in india and to encourage
people to go to our cinema
comfort and and and also the mere
factory they've got that separation
which is very important so it's really
important to promote our
sunrise
to the wider public
next council duty uh who is the segment
okay sorry country do you wish to speak
any further speakers council of our nuts
um just thank you for the change and the
recommendation because it seems strange
to written expenditure to ourselves um i
i'm yet to be persuaded this is the
right time for this report so but it'll
be discussed in the draft annual plan
process i'm
obviously we've seen great downturn and
people attending the cinema and that's
probably going to take at least the next
six months to a year to recover so i'll
be very interested to see that business
plan however
when businesses like this have a
downturn it does take a little while for
them to come back so i'm just going to
question the timer i think it's an
excellent idea i approve of the project
but i'm just concerned about timing
thank you for the speakers
i
don't disagree with some of the points
you make in council obama i support it
because
um they actually need this investment um
to be made but i would like um
appropriate senior managers to just make
sure that they've looked through that
business plan and uncomfortable jeff
from what he's advised is but i just
like to see that rugged but it's
appropriate that it's considered as part
of our budgets do you want to hear
something andy yes so just to sort of
support and give you a bit more
information in terms of i had a good
conversation with tinman cinema today
and i understand that
over the last two years there's been a
very much a restriction in the delivery
of and the release of new news new movie
releases um that is now called up on
itself so actually this year is actually
going to sort of be a return to norm so
they're now releasing all of that
backlog in 2022.
so and all those are coming through at
the end of christmas time so christmas
2022. so their
timing is actually probably quite a good
time because you we've now got the
facilities for them to maximize actually
those tick yourselves in those events
whereas actually if we had the
retractable ceiling
we they would still be selling every
second c and actually then we still have
the cover issues that are stopping
people to come
hopefully that gives you a little bit of
more of more of a comfort there in terms
of how that is
thank you council do you want to reply
yes um
thank you i was just going to mention
about that
the that our cinemas are starting to
really revamp up again now and it's
important that we
give them all the support we can
possibly can because it's important that
we keep our community in our area
thank you i'll put the recommendation
all those in favor please say aye
contrary
to that carrie thanks andy thank you so
uh jim are your wellbeing health and
safety report 555 to 566.
i'll tell you the reporters read the
only thing to note probably is with
there was a fatality if somebody
had been using our part for running
recreation purposes and passed away in a
toilet block so
it does turn up in the statistics here
but there's nothing that
we could do it's just unfortunate
for that person their family
thank you questions of jim
summer prepared to move council award
seconded councillor brian
uh any discussion
put that all those in favor please say i
can't declare that carried we now come
to a series of minutes
uh that 11.1 to 11.3 be received thanks
council meetings
secretary councillor stewart
um
would you like to highlight celine
at cnr i did indicate
uh i missed that meeting and i did
indicate well in advance of the meeting
that i was i did put in my apologies but
it's not
um recorded
on the meeting for the 14th of december
so um perhaps something adrian could
follow up yes
yeah
it's it's um it'd be fixed at the cnr
meeting but it's good for you to know
that adrian if we could just um just
looked at that i was not awol
appropriately recorded
so in moving that second i'll put those
minutes all those in favor please say hi
to clear that carried then community
board minutes 12.1
four thanks council becky moving there
secondly council williams
uh do you wish to speak to those nothing
to highlight in those board reports
so put that all those in favor of saying
contrary to clear that carried now jared
we just encountered it around the emoji
accounts i'll read the capital works
program review
uh whether we would
do that today um how long do you think
presentation would take
why don't we get through do you mind if
we get through the other items first
then we could come to that because the
memo doesn't actually resolve anything
it's just approving it
it's going to be a conversation with
eliquid members so maybe i'll get
through those first we could have a
short break and then come to that would
that be right
okay
yes we'll do that before we go and picks
so if i just move my diary um
631-635 moved by neville seconded by
joan any discussion
i'll put that all those in favor please
say aye contrary to cleric carried
council portfolio update so jim's going
to make sure we keep to
up to three minutes
um because we've got about to get
through still so just ewe relationships
um i meet with um tamari and
um
and
couple of weeks ago she just
i obviously explained um
communities fellow called democracy's
position with regards to three waters
there was some commentary
out pre-christmas that i think was
perhaps a little misunderstanding what
position was
we're going to hit forum with
uh mias and ewi in a couple of weeks
here to explain
our position further
we've got mahita mahitahi uh next week
um but apart from that i've got nothing
else to report at this point
any questions
uh greater christchurch partnership
there's nothing really to report on um
in our meeting pre-christmas
i think we've reported back since then
we haven't had a meeting for the year
but there's obviously the spatial
planning work underway
it was quite a discussion in our last
meeting around the um
connect up work around
transport uh
and um some other
we we we think we just need to keep
together you can in the city were
wanting to go and talk to the minister
and we said it would be very good if we
could have make sure that it's a
connected conversation so
that's really where the last
item i can recall to update on nikki or
nibbles or anything you want to add
any questions
can we call water management strategy
cassandra
thank you um the water zone committee
met yesterday
um and some interesting um safar merged
um
you'll be aware of the actual
braided river revival
program which is a major
ecam project
several
zone committee members
were critical really of the
revival
and the piecemeal projects that he can
there's a there is a plan that we were
all given with
bits here and there and
some of it is the recreation that um
involved has planned which is in
replanting which has come out of the the
felling of the trees this shingle
extraction issues bird nesting
um flood management and the question
being
a braided river revival reviving what to
achieve what
and
there was
silence
and this came from several
zone members saying so what is the whole
revival
meant to achieve where is the vision for
this
river system
what do we want what has wanted to
achieve over
25 50 perhaps 200 years
um using two high tower trusts type of
approach
and there was nothing so there is a new
well we're going to get a presentation
from a new ecan staffer
who has been taken on board to advance
this revival program
and you know seriously
where is this heading what is the vision
for this river
who knows so um
a zone committee members welcome to
having a talk initially to
the person that's in charge of the
revival wherever that's meant to go
so
further discussion too on the
zone committee
action plan budget
50 000
has been allocated for the
uh year which ends um in june
and and
the zone committee is still finalizing
projects i've got four um
on board that need a bit more budget
information totaling 27 000 of the 50
000 and that's um
taranaki stream
some contribution into um
planting to encourage more
white baits spawning
septon softwood creek monitoring that's
a catchment project with um property
owners and carolyn nathan is
leading a bit of that the northbrook um
you're gonna have to
it's three minutes so you might just
want to circulate your points by email
we just yep
okay thank you
um international relationships typical
americans and
thank you mr mayor i'm just trying to
look at how i'm going to get into three
minutes but the meeting that we're going
to have is on the 28th so we've got
nothing at the moment i'm not sure i can
stretch it any further than that thank
you
regen council blacky
what to report i was away for 20 days
and surprise surprise the wood kept
turning without me i discovered when i
got back but um report on aqualand
going great guns down at the lake um
their peak day hit 2005 hit 450 people
one one day over the summer they are in
any war hot to warm day they're getting
between 250 and 300 and even on a poor
day they're getting around 75 75-80
so they're very happy it's all going
very well there's only one resident left
there who's grumpy about all the others
have come on board and are now talking
to them and and totally happy
the only problem they've got is the bird
life um
pooping on the thing when they when
they've gone home
the good news about that is they only do
it on the on the climb out beds pretty
much and they have solved the problem
the there's four swans who are the main
perpetrators there's a whole lot of
geese and they have swat fix the geese
problem by buying two of those blow up
crocodiles that you put in a swimming
pool and the geese have bugged off
near the place since the crocodile but
the swan has been photographed standing
on one of the crocodiles
that is my report thank you
thank you counselor
excellent climate change sustainability
accounts for the meetings tough to
follow damn
uh look not a lot has happened and the
climate change and sustainability
um
space over the holidays but um that's
kind of i guess what i'm gonna report on
so as as you guys would be aware we had
a couple key staff leave at the end of
last year which kind of caused momentum
on progressing to the next stage of our
sustainability strategy implementation
and um and certainly put a paws on us
taking it out into the community so
but also what happened at the tail end
of 2021 was the merging a policy the
policy and strategy unit and the
business and centers unit which has now
formed a new strategy and business unit
which is going to be um
led by simon hart
um that took place mid december just
before we all took off for christmas um
that unit is going to be developing and
implementing uh key council strategies
that go across all the
all of our silos if you will um beyond
service delivery and also those um
into the community and relating to
sustainability and climate change so
that's the new unit that we'll be
looking after this
with that new unit the role of lead
advisor of sustainable development has
been established with the
with the purpose of leading advice and
developing and implementing that
um those those strategies and um
the council let's see um that they give
effect to the un's sustainable
development goals that we've adopted in
our ltp and they are looking to start
recruitment for that shortly if i'm not
wrong
and um
look it resourcing permits we're looking
to re-energize and extend
the sustainability practices and to get
out into the community
as per the direction that we set in our
ltp
and
yeah and hopefully we'll get the
sustainability champions and the
steering group and that back up and
running simon hart's gonna be the the
unit manager overseen by um simon
markham who will keep a keen interest
and
um other than that we'll just be
watching um to see what the government
gets up to and then when it unveils its
national emissions reduction and climate
change adaptation plans so
not nearly as exciting as alligators and
swans but there is
[Music]
thanks nikki any questions
just sorry just a regional level of
climate change we the uh
steering group meet last week which iga
the climate change risk assessment um
report will be released shortly and
there'll be a briefing for us as
councillors also on the 18th of march
we're running these regular counsellor
workshops professor don hine is going to
be invited to come on i'm sorry i can't
remember what is
what his particular area is but
apparently he's very good so it's just
two updates from that from last week
business promotion and town center
councilwood
thank you
with the omicron
happening
unfortunately ranger promotions have
decided to cancel eats and beats on
march the 8th what's happening with
carpool is that been cancelled as well
you're not sure
yeah
okay that's fine
um so um so that's been kindled till
next year
um ev charges meridian are hoping to
install wood end in oxford
in march april this year
e-scooters are working very well an
update in march will come to council
good street is on track for construction
to start in may this year
just in the off season to get that all
prettied up
and new zealand motto
association in kaikoi is starting
construction but some variations are
still to be processed but in the
meantime
there that will make may do some delays
but in the meantime um
their starting was started and
oh cool
and planned for a much or maybe a little
later march opening but they're underway
so that's very good news
so that's me
thanks john any questions of jane
thank you so um i've got no questions
understanding all this there's no urgent
general business
um before we go on px we'll come back to
the memo but we've been going for a bit
now i think 10 minutes break would be
uh welcomed um so jira if we can prepare
to
uh do your memo and
pre-related presentation about 4 30 and
then we'll um
then we'll go into px thereafter right
thank you have a break everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
warm up for tomorrow
and to give you an idea of some of the
work we've been doing this year on our
capital works program
and some of the things that we're trying
to achieve
in that so it's really just giving you
an overview of the revised assessment
approach
we want to give you some assurance that
we've tried to size the capital works
program to our resourcing to so that
we've got the capacity to deliver what
we've got in the draft annual plan
and
this is probably something you've heard
jim um talking about and it's certainly
something that jim's been
um
looking for us to integrate into all of
our uh work as more of the linkages to
community outcomes with everything we do
so this spreadsheet actually goes a step
in that direction um trying to
show you where our capital will align
with the up with um with those
and
tries to quantify that but i'll go into
that
okay so um the
spreadsheets that you've only just got
there i'll go into each of these details
uh and
in there so this is just a bit of an
idea
to show you what
you'll see in those spreadsheets so if
every capital works product
there's um
qual there's
a whole series of columns and up at the
top
you'll see um
each of these things so the idea of this
is to just give you an idea that we've
been looking at those um
what have we got so just as an example
here in the water
the drivers uh for that um
if you look at
the waikoku uv installation a big driver
for that um as well
as the
statutory requirement whereas some of
those other projects you see listed
there
under statutes only see because the main
drivers are actually growth um or
potentially level of service
so we're trying to just give you an idea
of why why it is what's the reasoning
behind those capital works
um and the idea is we just use the
relatively
coarse
grading a b and c must do should do or
could do
just so that when the asset managers
were going through their head and had an
idea of how they um would assign whether
it was an a b or a
c for that priority
so hopefully this is making sense
um well it's essentially what we asked
for it is they're correct
in german you have worked on this
i think
things no
ordinary
briefings
so those priority colors um they relate
to their staff assessment column
um so yeah
yes but but you see like in the district
water in the top line yeah a is green
um but b should be blue and c should be
yellow sorry but yeah you've got b
yellow and c red inside yeah so we've
used um
things
for those of us yeah no no no
so if you go to the staff assessment
urgency
we've actually used that color coding
but you can't see it on this one but
you're quite right um
when we go to drivers we should actually
um see where it sees priority um we
should be clear that that's the staff
assessment
rather than
the drivers so we've used a different we
have used different color and we should
probably try it out for the future yeah
it's confusing
yes
so we'll give if you'd like we can give
you some um a3s before you go today
so you have a look at them yep
yeah okay
even at a three though they can't they
will be a bit big we'll do that before
before you finish day i mean because
they'll actually be helpful for you over
the next couple of days to understand
yep
okay
and also that might help answer your the
first question though nikki when you're
seeing a whole sheet um but you we
should have used the same colors i agree
so the column that says staff assessment
if you can see my dot we've used that
color for this column
but you're right these are we've used a
different color coding here
yep we'll get on to that we definitely
do that yeah yes
yep maybe if we let garrett get on and
present
so
no i'm not i'm not big now it's just
that this we've still got quite a bit of
issues
yep let's keep moving okay so then we've
got another section on these tables that
talks just to give you an idea of what
are the stakeholder expectations for
each of those projects so every single
one of those again every line item
you've got that information there
what's our current progress and what's
the required requirement for external
funding and that'll for example if it's
something that's
funding um whether it's a requirement or
also the shovel ready work so it helps
you understand
that from a priority point of view now
that has not been graded so that's just
purely information
for you but it's definitely been a
consideration in the staff assessment in
terms of giving it
[Music]
a little bit ahead of this before we got
to it and that's where we've got that um
that color key that you're referred to
counselor mailings um so we've
effectively gone through and manually
prioritized those or when i say where
it's not me it's the people sitting in
the back here and don who's done it all
um
and
yeah so uh
that's um that's been gone through but
there's been quite a bit of we've you
know been through quite a few workshops
to develop this and brainy consistency
not only actually with the new r but
also in green spaces as well
um
that's
kelly did you want to talk to that
because we
the idea of this is to introduce the
whole overview probably those sorts of
questions should be for tomorrow but
happy to check it out i think we're just
basically yeah
just to give you an overview of what
these sheets like and hopefully you can
have a look at them tonight
um
so this is the um
piece that is starting to go in the
direction that our chief executive is um
looking for us to do and we've been
working
to try and
basically do an assessment here of
in terms of the well-beings
what value is each of these project
adding and giving it a weighting so on a
project but project basis you can look
at it and go okay that's 20
economic benefit 20 social i'm sure you
won't agree with the assessment that's
been done
and
but it's it's a start and what it also
does is you can then look across all of
your capital works program and get an
idea of how much money is being put into
each of those well-beings
and ultimately this will this work would
further
give us much better alignment with the
community outcomes
so
this is
one of the things that um at this point
is being really put in there is display
benefits but by the time we've advanced
this i expect next year this will become
much more of a driver of our capital
works program but it's one of these
things it takes a bit of time to
implement
so
what this does is give you an idea of
the overall balance of your program if
you're interested in
safety or social issues environmental
issues then you can see well what are
projects and how are they rating against
those dimensions when you line it up
with statutory and those other factors
then you can make a course to what you
might want to put ahead of something
else and it's entirely possible to start
there and say well we think we need to
shift the dial
um put a third more into say
environmental programs
whether it's coming from
roading or transport or libraries you
would get a sense of that because
that and this is a tool that you
developed years ago and
we developed a model so it allowed any
project a new project to come and be
assessed against that you'd say well
strategically it's not heading in the
right direction do we have to do it by
law no why would you want to do it so it
it brings another lens because otherwise
the well-beings just sit there and
they're kind of a qualitative thing but
they're not linked into your decision
making
thanks jim
um so the other thing we've done in uh
this will answer one of the other
questions that came is we have actually
quantified
the workload and
the staff that are available for
capital work so this is not all of the
staff in pdu um there's still a whole
lot of other work that's non-capital
work related
but we've actually gone through a
process to quantify the amount of
work there is and try and align that
with our staff resources
now
we do have
we've actually got not bad match here
what we are showing is that our program
as it currently stands is
slightly ambitious for our current staff
resources and we've taken a fairly
conservative approach there so we've
allowed some you'll see this contingency
built into this so um and this is
detailed in the memo that you've got on
the agenda if you want to have a better
look at it but we have made some
allowance so what we're saying um
is
if you sort of look here we're working
out that you need about 15 people to
deliver that work with contingency in
and we've got about 13.
we have staff
coming and going
we know we've had resignations and new
recruitment but we've taken a pretty
again a fairly conservative approach
there um it's not assuming that we're
going to be able to fill vacancies um so
if we ended up in a position where we
were able to fill
a couple of extra vacancies we'll have
capacity um to deliver that
if not we've actually got it's not
actually too much to be able to put out
to get consultants to help us deliver
that but what it does also means if you
ended up
through your the next couple of days
taking some of those capital works out
of the program
um we
we're not going to end up without work
to do so there's still you know we do
actually you do have the ability to
remove some of those projects if you
wish to and i think this is probably the
first time we've presented you
this kind of information in this way
where you actually can
make those decisions being conscious of
what that effect will have on
resourcing so uh we've
we're basically saying um we've got
enough to deliver for
uh the green space program um again
roading most likely and in there as some
slight under-resourcing of the three
waters so as i said we can either um
defer those works or we can bring in
some extra resource from consultants um
the other thing here on the right-hand
side of this and again you'll see this
in the memo we're we just show we've
done sort of a top-down assessment we're
actually um aiming for about a 40
million dollar uh program this year and
if you compare that to the current year
and the previous year you can see
there's a step down so
um
we've actually
uh
you know that's actually a very helpful
way to get a feel for is it manageable
how many dollars have we spent over the
last few years managed to deliver um and
so this is
not what was budgeted this is what was
delivered um
and
we're um so you know it is a smaller
program so we're not
uh so that gives us a bit of confidence
that it's a realistic program that we're
putting in front of you
to tomorrow and the next day so um
that's that's pretty much the end of the
presentation a couple of quick questions
because we're going to have plenty of
time to go through this well hopefully
we'll have time to go through it
tomorrow
uh next couple of days nibble
morning questions
what we asked for very very well
okay
i think i i don't think there's any
further comment that needs to be made at
this point
thank you for that heads up that's
really good
did you want to add something no no
i know you've got c so you okay
you're okay so i'll just
with that um we're now going to move
thanks during the team and now to move
into um
public excluded can i have someone for
the reasons moved by council berkey
seconded by council duty
uh i'll put all those in favor please
say i
contrary to clear that carries so just
wait for adrian to do her thing
and you'll
get time to um get into the pigs
you